orange is the worst flavoring known to
man i think orange is like strong are
you from australian sarcasm or are you
like actually serious
what's up lads welcome to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
your boy joey and i'm with my other two
boys and connor and we are back in japan
where are we right now what is this
place where are we you know what's scary
i realized just today that it's been
three months since we've recorded here
yeah has it actually yeah the last time
we filmed which was the goodbye japan
episode i think was like mid-may that we
recorded that well i recorded a trash
taste podcast episode was like june
something yeah so it's been a month in
l.a right that we last recorded yeah
it's been it's been over a month since
we recorded our last trash taste it's
been three months since we were here
yeah so uh i don't know how to podcast
yeah well uh i guess welcome back to the
japan studio guys uh the la arc is not
over yet we just thought you guys might
just miss just the three of us have a
bit of a breath
we're gonna have a little bit of a
breather and just come back with just
the three of us because we haven't
actually been able to talk about
anything that we've done abroad yet sure
talk sure let's let's talk but uh as you
guys can see from the title of this
episode uh the first topic we're going
to be talking about is our tour yeah
so we've announced it now tickets are on
sale but i know there's been a lot of
questions that's been up in the year uh
just because we haven't really been able
to talk much about it on the podcast
because we've been busy on a different
tour
but yes we will be touring north america
even though it's just like all of
america and then one show in canada it's
north america guys it's north america
the canadians are like yeah
i know a lot of people asked uh okay
there's been a ton of questions about
the tour yeah because like a lot of
people like because we're too fair we
haven't been very good at explaining
what's yes yes uh the first one was why
not other locations uh well the main
reason we chose america i think is
because uh it just made sense and it was
easier
yeah well also uh logistics and most
more importantly visas
yeah visas is a massive headache uh so
when you want to go to a like a
southeast asia tour or a europe tour um
we would have to think way more than uh
what we would need to do in america
because that's basically just one
country
and that's taken up enough resources
just setting up this one tour because
the reason we wanted to do this tour is
that we've wanted to do a tour since
cove it happens right yeah yeah yeah i
mean we've been planning this for about
like a year or so uh as an as a back
burner idea and then suddenly the world
opened up and we were just like guys
we're going to do it now we've got to do
it now
not knowing that we kind of slid this
tour in on possibly like already the
busiest year of our lives oh no it's
absolutely the business yeah yeah
exactly for sure but like yeah i guess
the other reason as well like we chose
america specifically because it's like
it's kind of on brand for trash taste
you know yeah if you've been on uh our
afternoon streams especially uh which by
the way you totally should if you
haven't then uh we uh we like to talk
about america listen we
it's obvious we're obviously we're
obsessed with the americans yeah
but also our biggest audience is in
america so this just made the most sense
really and you know we hate them because
we ain't them
we hate we just hate that we aren't you
yeah okay yeah and you know i don't
think we've ruled out the possibility of
doing tours in future in other locations
yeah is this but like it also no
promises that we'll ever do another
promises no because we might we might be
like oh no that was that was a lot yeah
we might [ __ ] hate it
none of us have ever been on a tour
before none of us have ever been close
to anything like this yeah so this is
new for all of us and so we figured you
know what better place to do it to start
it off than uh in a place that we're
hopefully a little more familiar with
when it comes to our audience and stuff
like that and uh you know
we should go around all the us none of
us have ever been around like every
single state yeah yeah yeah not even
close like like there's so much of
america considering how much we've [ __ ]
on america there's so much of america
that we've just never been to yeah yeah
absolutely what are you googling uh i'm
googling the exact cities that we're
going to be going oh yeah yeah okay so
keep keep talking guys i was going to
say because i saw one comment that was
like it's so [ __ ] they talk about
america because they've only been in l.a
well [ __ ] you this is what i'm doing
yeah i'm going around all of your
country absolutely not sure i am going
to all of your country so that i can say
that i know your country better than you
and i will talk [ __ ] about it how many
states have you guys been to so far
quite a lot actually yeah i feel like i
think you guys have been to more than me
yeah i bet you fair amount of states
actually yeah yeah i've been like maybe
10 or 15. i'd say probably around that
area as well yeah yeah i mean because
i'm sorry montana what am i going to do
montana
why montana specifically because i've
never heard anyone talk about montana
sorry dakota the only thing i know about
montana is hannah and that's it
i mean that's all you need to know she
has done more pr for the state of
montana than anyone else hey hey hey hey
tony from scarface tony it's tony
montana tony montana
he might not even be from montana i
don't know that might just be a name
i hate to i hate to break your heart god
i think hannah montana is a little more
street cred currently is hannah montana
based in montana i don't even know i
think it's tennessee
tennessee
which we will be going to tennessee
actually can you fact-check
that where is hannah montana where is
hannah montana from
i don't know this i was obsessed but to
name all of the places that we're going
to be going go forward we're going to be
going to singapore in minneapolis
chicago illinois
paul minneapolis that was where i was
deported
hey yo it's the come back tomorrow
i'm coming back
uh cleveland ohio yep i've never been to
ohio never been to detroit uh detroit
michigan uh toronto ontario
uh boston massachusetts
philadelphia never mind um what's what's
that
what philadelphia yeah is
uh pennsylvania pennsylvania that's it
yeah yeah
uh new york city new york washington d.c
what you didn't know pennsylvania i
don't know my american states
unfortunately
uh relay rayleigh
north carolina nashville tennessee
orlando florida dallas and austin in
texas
i mean texas is a big state yeah yeah
yeah kansas city in
you got this i know you got it come on
do you know your states no i don't
what's what's the initials ammo what's
our [ __ ] i've already failed the america
geography test is it
montana
no it's not
i was like what starts with an ammo
montana i know that one gonna save us i
actually don't know this one wait ammo
is uh
well we got this we got this
i thought kansas city was in kansas
but it's not i found out today that
kansas is not a state so it's uh no
kansas is a state but kansas city is not
in kansas this is missouri
okay missouri sought that out wait hold
on kansas city yeah no it can't be mi
because michigan that's why oh yeah
kansas city okay hold on let's get this
straight so
kansas city is not in kansas
how does that make sense
because there is a kansas city in canada
i'm pretty sure as well oh so there's
two kansas cities well it's like how
there's like a billion londons god damn
it okay okay anyway
guys we haven't even started yet we're
already complaining we're already
complaining
so
missouri is like right next to kansas
yes yeah i think kansas city is
literally like 10-minute [ __ ] drive
oh really i think maybe i'm i maybe have
pollock it's very close missouri's like
that's ours now yeah i think so i think
they were like let's just take that over
we've got denver colorado yeah salt lake
uh salt lake city soul play
flake if you don't come to the city
salt lake city in utah phoenix arizona
la san francisco in california uh
seattle in washington and portland
oregon nice see i haven't been to most
of those places yeah i i've always
wanted to go
it's been like a dream of mine to always
just go around the us anyway oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i think i think that's part of the
reason why we wanted to do this tour
which was it's a reason for us to go to
all the places we've wanted to go in the
us and we've just never had the
opportunity uh to go to before hold on i
think we're getting breaking news
where's hannah montana from
oh my god oh i know my [ __ ]
bigger question why is hannah montana
called hannah montana why is it not
hannah 10. because it doesn't work
because hannah tennessee doesn't rhyme
well then based it on montana
what the [ __ ] okay
what the [ __ ] tv
but yeah no as god was saying like it's
a great excuse for us to actually go
around america and i feel like we'll
actually be able to on this tour we'll
be able to get kind of a more i guess
in-depth look into america as well
because we'll actually be on a tour bus
which yeah i'm really excited for
yeah as like someone who's like super
into like rock music and stuff and just
like seeing rock bands go on like tour
buses and stuff i'm like i want that i
think i'm i i think i'm excited for the
idea of a tube of a tour bus you know
yeah i'm not yeah i heard that you don't
have a poop on it so yeah yeah i'm
disappointed because i like to have
boundaries oh well it's uh five weeks of
constipation then boys yeah because i've
seen pictures and basically we're just
going to be in bunk beds for an entire
closed bunk beds yeah close bunk beds
for an entire two months we're basically
going to be asking that's fine yeah
we're basically just going to be in a
space shuttle for like a month right
yeah doesn't that sound cool
i mean it's going to be a real test of
our friendship i mean these guys cool i
i i love these guys i love these guys
but i don't know how i'm going to be
after sitting with them for like what
was it five weeks which one for five
years in a cramped little bus i think uh
i think like aaron was especially saying
um that like
definitely what makes a tour bus
experience the best is if you have like
a tour family quote unquote which is
like you know like all of the other like
producers and like tour people who are
coming on with you like if you can vibe
with them yeah then it makes the tour
bus experience a million times better
right so fingers crossed we have a nice
tour family otherwise we're going to be
at each other's throats but um yeah i
mean i guess like you know because we
chose the tour bus experience i think
because it's you know for one i feel
like you get to see more of america yeah
you know because we're going to be
driving from you know city to city and
stuff like that whereas like i don't
know if you fly you i feel like you miss
a lot of what goes on in between you
know yeah exactly because it's kind of
like there there are some places where
people say they've visited but you've uh
but really they've just visited like the
airport right you know and i don't
really count that or you like visited
the city yeah but like you haven't
really like actually seen outside of the
cities of america and you know yeah
we're talking about america there's a
lot of outside the city let's be honest
guys we're trash tastes we're here to
make america content right
we're here to get the stories
i mean we will be vlogging the entire
thing as well so you guys who aren't
attending the tour will you know still
get something out of it hopefully i
think a lot of america is very similar
though like americans like to pretend
like it's very diverse but if you look
at like any pictures of any road in
america they all look exactly the same
save it save it okay yes because because
we can we we would be able to confirm
that yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying this
now let's see if i still feel this way
keep the bar low so that when cool
things do happen we can be like
okay
just monstrosity gas stations that are
massive they're like the middle of the
highway yeah because i've seen some of
them some of the dentist office yeah
yeah in the middle of like guest stop
it's insane do you think people are
going to still be complaining about gas
prices by the time we get there yeah
that's that's i i hope it is because
otherwise i don't know how to talk to
people in the u.s that's that's my
opening line every single time the
ultimate icebreaker
it's the american life hack if you want
to start a conversation you just talk
about gas prices it works every single
day and they're like oh thank god he's
on my side
but yeah i guess the other thing as well
for you guys who have potentially
already bought tickets or are thinking
about buying tickets uh is uh you know
what we're going to be doing what can
you do what can you expect what can you
expect and you know obviously we don't
want to give too much away because we
wanted to you know keep an element of
surprise for you guys who are actually
coming on tour but um let's just say it
won't just be this it won't just be us
yeah it's not just a talk show yes it's
it's not a live podcast
if that's what you were thinking there
will be some of that there will be a
little bit of talking yes just just a
little bit of talking but if you were
expecting some of the panels that you
might have seen get leaked online from
like us at like ax
or also like any other conventions that
we've been to in the past few months
it's going to be a bit more of like it's
going to be a bit of that but more crowd
interactions and more bringing what you
know trash taste for onto a live stage
yeah as much opportunity as much
opportunity to get you guys involved
with uh some of the [ __ ] that we get up
to on stage yeah so you guys won't
merely just be sitting in the crowd you
know hopefully laughing to our [ __ ]
jokes like you guys will actually be
involved with the show yeah there'll be
some segments where
a lot of your interaction yes uh will be
required and it should lead for some
interesting results because yeah you
know because we're doing the show a lot
of you know we're gonna be doing this 20
times yeah we want it to be different
every time yeah so one of the main
reasons that we decided we want to get
as much viewer interaction as possible
is that all right we want to make it so
that we don't get bored of teams yeah
yeah that every single show is different
but also can we try and like suss out
some of the segments i wonder if i do
this the next time it'll it'll yeah yeah
yeah exactly it'll it'll kind of be like
a a growing theme for us as well with
every show as well so i did see a lot of
people in the comments and stuff like
that being like oh are they just going
to like talk on stage for now short
answer is no it'll be a lot more than
that basically if you've heard some of
our takes or some of the [ __ ] that we've
said and you've ever wanted to clown on
us in real life this is probably the
closest
this is this is this is the closest
you're ever going to get because we're
going to give you that opportunity yeah
that's that's all i'll say about that
yeah yeah yeah i saw a lot of people
asking like oh what's the how long do
you reckon the show is going to be uh we
still haven't like 100 percent decided
the exact timing because we haven't
rehearsed it all yet no but we've been
going through it we reckon it'll be
around i don't know like hour 45 to
maybe just two hours yeah yeah so you
know should be a good show yeah because
i think we've been to like a few live
shows in the past few months we went to
uh mogul money live yeah at ludwig's
live event as well and that definitely
taught us a lot because i was thinking
man two hours is just like a normal
trash taste episode right i don't know i
don't know if that's like long enough
for like something special but
what i've realized being in a live show
is that you can't just pause the show
that's the big thing i've noticed is
that you can't just pause trash taste
and just go off and do your own thing
and then come back you're going to be
sitting there for the full time and
there will be breaks maybe here and
there but we want to make the show as
entertaining as it possible for everyone
sitting down because it's not like a
normal trash taste episode where you can
just take breaks you know you can go to
the toilet you can just put us on the
second monitor no we are main monitor
this time there is no other monitor okay
close those tabs there is only one tab
open
and it's us i think as well uh one of
the other things is that uh [ __ ] i
forgot what i was going to say and then
i had the thought
i had it in the forefront of my head and
then
i threw my head off yeah
uh uh i was going to say something
to do with the show it was sent through
the show okay and i forgot oh one of the
main things we i think we went into this
and when we planned out the show is that
because we understand that not every
single person who's gonna go to the show
is gonna be a gigantic trash taste fan
yep we have kept in mind we just want to
make a good show we didn't try to make
it of like a complete fan service thing
it's like if you want to just turn up
have hopefully a fun show should be
there yeah so if you you know say for
example you're the only one in your
friend group who watches and listens to
trash taste then there is i i think i
would like to think that like we've kind
of structured this show so that even if
you have the bare minimum idea of who we
are and what this show is yeah you can
hopefully still enjoy yourself yeah you
should be able to yeah so you can bring
a plus one you know you can bring your
friend who has maybe not doesn't know
anything about us and be like you want
to go watch three idiots on stage talk
about some [ __ ] and do some fun stuff
that's totally what it's gonna be yeah
yeah yeah we want to we wanted this to
be as newbie friendly as possible like
all our content uh we just wanted to i
guess like we just wanted to be this is
kind of like trash tasters final form
it's like taking everything that we've
learned from the podcast from after dark
yeah from touring around ultra instinct
this is ultra instinct trash taste we
are taking trash taste and we're just
cutting off all the fat and we're
condensing everything that you love
about trash taste into this one show
yeah um and and on top of that we got
exclusive merch for it as well right
yeah we do there is stuff that you can
get uh at the shows and only at the
shows um this is you know you guys have
been asking you know when's the next
merch drop and stuff like that which we
greatly appreciate uh so for you guys
who are going to the tour uh at every
location we will be selling exclusive
trash taste merch
stuff for the tour that you can only get
there and no we will not be selling it
online so if you really want that trash
taste merch you better come to the shows
that's all i'm gonna say to that yeah
i'm sorry south sea stations and
europeans who've been crying this entire
time yes
we might release something online during
that time maybe yes but no promises um
but yeah
yeah go for it no no but all i was
saying was that you know hopefully this
will be an event that you guys you know
even if it doesn't matter if you watched
us from day one or you just found us
found out about us last week like
hopefully everyone can enjoy the show
get involved and just have a good time
yeah that's all you want and for
everyone in everywhere else in the world
just like kind of crying right now not
being able to come to the america show i
think for for all three of us this is
kind of like a litmus test yes um
because we do i do want to travel to
more places i do want to travel to more
places across the world i mean i'd want
to travel to our home cities home
countries go on represent our own
[ __ ] regions right exactly exactly um
i think we are kind of using this tour
as a barometer not only for how natural
barometer
we're using it as a gauge okay
as a gauge not only to see how much it
affects our mental well-being doing a
tour this intensive uh but just seeing
if this is financially viable to uh
pursue visas and all the logistics in
other places that might be more
difficult as well um so you know
americans please show up because you
might give the chance to uh other people
from around the world to be able to
experience what you're experiencing as
well yeah yeah and uh i think that's
basically everything we want to like
kind of like spoiler so if you're
watching uh this episode right now and
you were kind of on the fence of whether
you want to come to the show or not then
uh yeah trash taste tour.com yeah a lot
of them are already sold out so i
believe la is sold out uh san francisco
is sold out orlando i think orlando
florida is sort out new york is sold out
uh at the time recording toronto is just
about to sell out so is seattle um and
there's very limited tickets for
uh minneapolis and chicago sorry sin
paul's and chicago yeah um and a lot of
them are filling up fast so
get them while you have the opportunity
because
by the time this release a few more
cities might have sold out so yeah we
don't actually know so don't wait don't
hesitate the tickets will probably go
out of stock at some point so yeah you
know yeah [ __ ] that out i can't
don't hesitate just buy the tickets buy
them now oh yeah there's also a couple
of cities uh left where you can also get
vip tickets as well where you can get a
bunch of other perks such as a one-hour
pre-show which is kind of like a more
intimate i guess panel with the three of
us yeah kind of like more of a cure
yeah and also some other exclusive merch
that only vips can get as well so if you
are also wondering about that those are
going a lot faster as well so if you
want to get on those you should probably
get on those as soon as you can by the
way yeah trashtaster.com link's in the
description yeah please come and see us
live uh we promise i'll see your faces
yeah we want to interact with you i
promise we will put on a good show for
you guys are you guys feeling about it
yeah it's like i'm like 50 excited 50
scared yeah i i just kind of think once
we've
done the first show i'll know how i'm
going to feel yeah right right right
just kind of hope it goes well so sam
paul please treat us well
you guys are setting the standards man
please don't tilt us too much too much
no because like
this is one of those things where we all
agreed to it like very early on okay
we're going to do this i think
especially looking at our tour schedule
and tour like our our schedule and
breaking down logistics and what we're
gonna do on tour i went from yeah this
is a great idea to like holy [ __ ] this
is that's a lot of work terrifying yeah
and now especially we've just come back
from traveling for about two and a half
months i'm already [ __ ] knackered
from traveling right sure
yeah regardless of whether this tour
does well or not and if we decide to do
future tours uh it's probably not gonna
happen for a while because just well not
this year at least at least not this
year because all three of us are it's
not even possible to do this yeah yeah
because all three of us are definitely
absolutely [ __ ] knackered yeah
touring already or just not touring but
like traveling i guess uh you know which
we can talk about because it's been uh a
while since we've talked yeah it has
well it's not been awhile since we've
talked it's been a while it's been a
while since we talked about what we did
yeah
this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn lads watching netflix without
using expressvpn is kind of like going
to a taylor swift concert but only being
able to watch the opening act
let me just say why would why would
anyone want it why would you do that
well you see gentlemen that's exactly
what netflix does netflix has different
content libraries for every country
which means even though netflix has
thousands of shows without a vpn you can
only get access to a fraction of the
shows that are available with expressvpn
you can control where netflix or other
streaming sites think that you're
streaming from connor what have you been
watching on netflix recently well i've
been in a real angry mood so i wanted to
watch brad pitt's fight club but
unfortunately it's only available in the
uk neph what so i have to do something
that nobody wants to do and return to
the uk just to watch it but thanks for
expressing and i don't have to go back i
can just change my location thank you
thank god so don't be stupid be smart
stop paying full price for streaming
services and only getting access to a
fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com trash
taste that's
expressvpn.com trash taste get an extra
three months for free don't back to the
episode yeah yeah movie yeah because we
did we've been traveling i think for
like how long have you guys been
traveling because i've been traveling
for almost three months i don't really
count the week i was back i was
traveling
you've been traveling all right i was
traveling for a little over two months
i think i was just under two months yeah
it's way too long
because one thing i think i've realized
is that we tried to like
like test a lot of little things to see
if this tour would be possible one thing
was this intense travel schedule that we
had over the past three months to be
like can we do this without going insane
well it definitely [ __ ] burnt not
burned me up but it definitely took a
toll but it didn't make me go insane
that's a good thing yeah and also we did
uh we announced the road trip special as
well oh yes yeah yes did so we have
spent a week an intensive week with each
other in the same car yeah that was a
lot that that was a lot yeah that that
[ __ ] was how nine days was it that was
including travel was ten days yeah ten
ten whole days oh yeah well i mean
that'll be out by the end of october
yeah so that'll be fun yes and uh it
should be a big boy long special that
would be a big boy long special so we've
already got a taste big name big boy
that's what the ladies call me
so we've already got a taste of what
it's like to be with these boys for like
10 days mm-hmm don't be able to go
anywhere that was worse though because
the car was tiny that's true at least
the bus we can you know walk around yeah
we have at least our own private
quarters but yeah i guess we should talk
about the special after it's come out
yeah
just look forward to it yeah it's gonna
be a good one yeah i'm i'm hoping that
my car sickness is better on a bus it is
all right
on a bus definitely yeah right right
because you're in a [ __ ] freight
train equivalent of a car like yeah
you're moving in a building
you know because when you're in a tiny
car the back of the car gets [ __ ] with
suspension yeah yeah
like it's you you get like thrown around
you're on a bus it's so big did you get
motion sickness on a train
no oh then you should be good okay
because i remember like
i remember on the road trip there was
like a lot of downtime in the car and i
was like i could read manga or watch
anime or play games and i like got read
one chapter of a manga and i'm like okay
can't do that and basically it was just
a lot of a lot of me just listening to
[ __ ] music and uh just darling out
pretty much i wish i could do more and i
think that's why it felt so exhausting
because i wanted to do more stuff on the
car just to like chill out but i
hopefully can do that on the tour bus
there's like communal space there's like
tables and stuff in the car it's like
whatever can fit on your lap is
technically the table yep so that that
also makes you just not want to work or
do anything like i just i'm not
comfortable this is awful the same thing
on a plane right yeah yeah it's like an
economy where you're like i'm gonna work
and then you'll realize your laptop
doesn't even open up fully yeah like
because you can't even like actually get
90 degrees because the chair especially
if the chair in front of you is leaned
all the way back it's just like yeah
yeah oh dude
i've got to say the worst flight i've
ever been on was the was the la to miami
flight at like
oh the economy flight yeah it was
[ __ ] awful yeah because like the
moment the flight hadn't even taken off
and you know you can't even like move
i'm sorry we got one on like uh a detour
here no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
welcome back to trash days yeah so
actually we're like a billion flights
yeah
and so we've got the red-eye flight from
la to miami and normally when you're on
a flight people wait until the plane is
like in the air and the seat belt things
got off before they recline no not on
this flight it was just like immediately
sat down dude full reclined and i was
like oh this is going to be there like
this all right okay i saw i saw people
as they were walking up to their seats
just grabbing the back of the seat
reclining it back and then sitting yeah
yeah just like chill
we have six hours on this flight you can
do it whenever it's a red-eye flight
right yeah i assume people were just
like these were seasoned veterans
i'm ready to sleep yeah i'd never been
on a flight before people like everyone
was calling right before the moment of
takeoff and the moment the plane touched
the ground not even like a taxi or
anything everyone's whipped out their
phones started making calls and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this
i didn't even notice that i didn't
notice that no because we landed in
miami at like [ __ ] 5 30 in the
morning i'm just like struggling to open
my eyes so i just couldn't [ __ ] see
anything yeah i don't know if i'm the
dumb one i probably am um but i don't
like stand up right away when the plane
takes the plane lands and in america bro
it was like a summoning salt video
people were trying to like clip through
the chairs trying to get their luggage
out right away they'd be like holding
their luggage like this just to stand up
for like 10 minutes standing up on the
first available frame
i'm sitting on the end and i can tell
this guy next to me is visibly getting
annoyed that i'm not standing up right
yeah because we're in the back yeah
we're not going anywhere yeah yeah we
literally are lashed to get on the only
reason i would stand up in a situation
like that is if my knees are killing me
which they were on that flight because
the seats were [ __ ] tiny so i was
just like i just need to [ __ ] stretch
out my legs yeah so then i'll stand up
for a bit you know maybe you know do
some exercise a little bit but then i'll
just yeah
i don't know if i'm missing something
like i don't know why people stand up
right away when there's
maybe they think they can just like
quickly [ __ ] go to the front yeah if
you're in a rush and you have a
connection i can kind of understand the
the you know the impatience but even
then it's like max you save a minute max
yeah yeah because you got to wait until
the doors open anyway so you're going to
be standing up for like a good 5-10
minutes right yeah that like
again that it's like you even if you
stand up first and you're in the front
you're still not getting off until they
open the goddamn doors like i get that
you want to get ready but you you know
when you can see the crowd moving you
know it makes sense if you're in like
premium economy and you're at the front
of the yeah yeah yeah because you also
have room then as well
[Music]
because like in in economy you can see
where the line goes and people go in
order anyway yeah right because
even if you're sitting down you know
there's there's an order to this there's
an order to this chaos otherwise there
isn't an [ __ ] like 10 seats back
being like out of the way out of the way
whatever you can't like yeah a fight
would happen yeah yeah but even every it
doesn't matter where i've gone in the
world everyone every country does this
yeah i don't know why there's just
people on the plane that stand up
immediately and they're like i'm getting
off first and then max they save 10
seconds
and i mean if it's just purely uh my
legs hurt i want to stand up all right
it's totally fine i get that but you can
tell who the the flight veterans are
because they're the ones who usually
just remain seated
i'm lazy as [ __ ] i'm i'm if i have 10
minutes left on my my netflix thing i'm
watching that until i get kicked off
what doesn't make sense is when people
do this on international flights right
because you get up you save your 10
seconds you're like [ __ ] yes i've saved
10 seconds you've got to wait [ __ ]
half an hour to get your bags anyway
yeah it doesn't make any difference
you're going to be leaving the airport
at the same time anyway that's true and
like customs as well you don't know how
long that's going to be i i honestly
just do it at a pure instinct
yeah i don't know i don't even think
about it anymore i think i think for me
for the most part i do it again not to
because i want to get out of the plane
quickly which i do but i know i'm not
realistically going to for me it's just
i need to stretch my legs that's fair
enough
because like because if it's i know
because if i know it's taking a while
then
yeah
because i just
because if i know it's taking a while
i'll just sit back down yeah yeah yeah
you're like ah that's too early i was
like oh damn i'm missing okay i will say
that on that one flight it had one thing
that i'd never seen before and i think
that every flight should have this from
now on
so right where the tv normally was uh
there's no tv on this on this flight but
like you know where it is right yeah
yeah so they had this thing that popped
out and it was a phone holder oh yeah so
it would it would have your phone you
could just put your phone or ipad in
this thing and it would just be like i
love okay because i was about to
complain about one thing in every flight
which is uh now that we've flown so many
times within the past few months i've
basically seen every every movie i want
to see
on like the flights right i know i know
the [ __ ] catalogue i know the library
okay that is the most first world
problem ever
no it's just like someone when you're
traveling for business there's no
entertainment left when when you've just
watched everything okay look i've look
there's only so many times i can see the
entire library of harry potter on there
and that one episode of [ __ ] hbo show
you know like i've wanted to load up my
own season three episode four yeah yeah
well on unlike some flights where you
have to like
so like when you have to load up on your
phone or an ipad or something you're
like oh this is a great idea i can just
watch what i want but unfortunately the
[ __ ] tray tables that come out means
that you have to like watch it like like
yeah yeah
or you just put your phone flat on the
table and you just watch it like this
both are horrible for your neck yeah
exactly and i finished that [ __ ]
plane at that plane flight with a
[ __ ] 80 year old neck and i have to
like
you know
you know
i definitely need to visit a
chiropractor afterwards because you just
[ __ ] your neck up you cannot [ __ ] get
off the plane
okay actually actually actually actually
actually question question what is your
guys's sleeping like
what is your sleeping position on a
plane
like what is how how do you feel normal
position
are we talking like an economy yeah
economy oh bro i i look like i'm about
to like die
i i like i like kneel over like i put my
head but like between my legs if i can i
saw you doing that on the on the florida
flag like how the [ __ ] is he sleeping
like that i tried to because like i
i thought you were throwing up no no no
no i like because for me
i don't know why i just i i cannot sleep
sitting up right i need to feel like my
head is resting on something like this
or like yeah at this i don't know
i'm the same though maybe it's like the
pressure on my head kind of makes me i
don't know why no i'm the same i need to
feel like like i'm leaning on either
side
so what i do is i take the you know the
seat at the back like the cushion thing
most of those cushion things you can
kind of fold the edges yeah yeah like
that so what i do is i do that and then
i kind of yeah it doesn't doesn't work
that does that doesn't work but that's
the best we've got
now i got to work with what i've god
guys the reason i ask is because i don't
know what it is about planes where any
other form of transportation you there's
enough room to get like a decent decent
sleeping position i think i i can't i'm
decent enough i'm i'm like i'm i think
i'm like wider than you
so like
like you call yourself dummy thing
my frame is just larger like you're
taller but i have like a wider frame i
swear that's like that it sucks because
if you're tall you can just like origami
yourself into a position or right
you're like
my arms are gigantic right [ __ ] giant
biceps right obviously you're not
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
i i i got a dummy ass right
now because i have i have this dilemma
right of like i need something to i need
to be leaning my face like the sides of
my face on something to get even just
like
a tiny amount of sleep yeah so then you
might be thinking well joey just sit on
the window seat because then you can
just lean against the wall no that
doesn't work my problem is that that
works except i have the bladder the size
of a peanut and so i have to get up
every like hour or two to go to pee and
so i need to sit on at least the aisle
seat because otherwise i just feel
[ __ ] horrible for the two other
people i'm sitting next to right so now
i'm stuck in this dilemma of like do i
prioritize my bladder or do i prioritize
my sleep and most of the time i just
prioritize my bladder so i just have to
[ __ ] deal with this thing yeah see my
my plain sleep nerf because everyone has
a plain sleep nerf like a condition that
has to be met
um is that my head needs to be like
beyond 45 degrees otherwise it doesn't
feel like i'm actually like sleeping
right so when when i see people sleeping
next to the window with their with their
heads on the window like i literally
cannot get my head at a like a cute
enough angle to like trick my brain into
thinking i'm going to understand that i
think that's why i like leaning forward
like for me i think it's certain about
like the pressure on my head or like the
way that i don't know how the blood's
flowing yeah it makes me like it like
recreates how i sleep
i'm not we're basically going to like a
coma patient you just
yeah
so the reason why i choose the aisle or
the window and i don't go for the middle
it's because on the on the middle one
the only place you can put your head why
are you laughing so much
i am a comatose patient just imagine the
one time like if connor ever gets into
like a plane crash and the pilot goes
everyone regretted your brace position
can literally fall asleep and he'll be
in the brace position all right fall
asleep in the race position okay that's
right
it's comfortable it makes sense the
reason why you're bracing it
so
as i was saying before godly rudely
and if i lean in the middle i can only
go straight and my head will hit the
chair and i can't get my head into the
position i want because it's too close
yeah because i i can't just get it in
enough and it'll like push against my
neck yeah if i if i do
so i have to do the window because the
window the thing that the downtown by
the window right
is that uh there's a little gap between
the window and the chair yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i put my head in that little
crevice
so as long as the guy behind me doesn't
randomly like try to tickle my head i'm
good and i do the same thing on the
aisle but the problem is if you do on
the islands risky because if they bring
the car they wake you up
[Music]
when i said i lean on the window i i
obviously meant that the crack between
the window and the seat belt so you're
going forward so same as me no no i lean
kind of back oh into that crate oh you
lean forward into the crack yeah it's
like really forward
i would not want to sit in front of you
because then if i look this way it'd
just be like god feels so
in between the cracks
that'd be horrifying
everyone who sits in front of conor gets
them gets a gets a viewing of the
shining yeah
it pretty much imagine looks like that
yeah
they don't turn around
how often are you looking in that
[ __ ] crevice behind you well you know
if you might you know because sometimes
if you're sitting on the window seat the
window can be positioned a little bit
far back than what is normal so you know
what if your window's like back here and
you just look good
if you're being a little embarrassed and
having a good sleep i'll tell you i'll
take i'll take this how the [ __ ] do you
sleep like that again i don't know i
have wouldn't it make more sense to do
it on the back side i i can't like i
can't sleep lying down like like face uh
back down yeah and so
reclining the chair is just a beta
version wait how do you sleep normally
uh on my sides
oh so you can't sleep on your back i i i
sleep no i've never been able to sleep
with my back really so i sleep on my
side but like i want to say
if it's my side but my body is very much
leaning towards my stomach the face of
the bed all right right kind of like
like yeah
[ __ ] like i don't
yeah actually just exactly how like a
cat yeah
okay yeah i've tried the coma strap
because there's some times where i
couldn't go overseas
yeah because i've tried and that's where
like being tall is enough because i can
never like i can never get my body into
enough of a position where because when
when i try to lean forward yeah this is
like the this is like the most forward i
can go right i can't even get close like
the trait
even when all right even when say for
example you do have enough space to just
be able to squeeze in to lie on the tray
table yeah my back just [ __ ] no i
don't i don't like my trade table on my
knees
that's even further down yeah doesn't
that [ __ ] you back up uh maybe
i sleep so
[ __ ] hell your knees yeah jesus
christ
i put my arms on my knees as a pillow
i'm i feel i'm trying to i'm trying to
remember i feel more worried about your
back
no that would kill me
no the end of your knees you're on your
thighs
try it i'm going to lean back try it try
it
i don't think i can even do this because
i've i've i have a couple of friends who
have slept like they're just like that
no my back the shinji position my back
would
just the permanent shinji
he's like are you asleep or depressed
yeah i'll never tell you stretch
i i got another 5 10 and i was like stop
stop stop going stop stop
bro so the coma strat is a backup strat
yeah
the cop is risky because like you
you're rash putting your head in like
the crevice and you're relying on the
crevice right yeah right and you know if
they're playing shakes it's not as not
as bouncy as your bones right the shinji
strat is only open to those on the five
terms yeah right
it's just it's locked for us it's locked
discovered that the american airlines uh
chairs are really [ __ ] close together
compared to like because i've done it a
bunch in japan on the domestic a a
flight and i noticed you we have way
more room on those domestic economies
right right than the american airlines
one that was [ __ ] close those
american airline flights are so goddamn
compact yeah yeah yeah i'm not [ __ ]
around yeah any closer and i'd be
kissing the person in front of me yeah
like pretty much the head yeah
hope you're having a good flight
yeah but that that red-eye flight to
miami was rough yeah i mean you know i'm
glad we still did it because we got to
do the uh the ludwig barrier cut
tournament yeah yeah so so super fun we
did the ludwig bureau car which is mario
kart double dash but you can't drive um
but you have to down a b you have to you
can't drive
you can't drink and drive because that's
illegal and that's bad yeah but you have
to down your beer either before you
start driving or any point when you stop
if your car still completely stopped
yeah so we really wanted to do this
and uh ludwig said that it would start 2
p.m and our flight was at 3. there was
no way we could do it so we moved it to
a 9pm flight so we could make it yeah
right um but that flight was brutal that
was horrible yeah because we got to
miami at i think it was like five or six
a.m
and then we and that was the first day
of the convention as well so we had a
signing from 1 p.m that day so we got
luckily though the airport and the hotel
we were staying at were pretty close it
was like 15 20 minute driveway uh so we
just literally just got to miami got to
the hotel slept for as long as we could
and then immediately headed to the con
but that was still a chill con i enjoyed
that yeah miami was a really cool place
yeah i thought miami was really
beautiful um obviously i wish i just
wish we had more time to actually kind
of explore miami yeah yeah cause i was
gonna ask because i've never been to
florida before um like how was florida
in general did you meet florida man did
you meet luckily luckily not luckily not
people were more chill in florida than
la i think i feel like it was um the
food was really good
food the cuban restaurant was insane
human food was nutty my god we were
[ __ ] up there we were so full so much
so much so
much uh like peruvian food another day
and that was really good yeah yeah yeah
yeah approved that hummus they made this
was insane remember that peruvian so did
you only stay there for the weekend of
the convention uh yeah yeah yeah we
landed on the the first day of the con
and then we left the morning of the day
after yeah it was good though i mean i
i'd like to go back to miami at some
point and just be a tourist yeah yeah
but also there's a lot of old people in
miami i didn't notice that yeah it
wasn't as young as i thought it would be
but i guess it's a lot of old people
retiring i guess yeah so i saw a lot of
60 year old looking men that were bronze
basically
with with uh with six-year-olds
permanently who were bronze as well and
i was like
so is this is miami just a glorified
retirement home that's why all the
buildings are really bright it's so that
you can find the people
yeah
no but miami was really fun it was like
too humid though oh it's like
yeah it was basically japan wouldn't
talk to me about humidity right now guys
it's basically what you're feeling here
is what it was like in my mind it was
too much it was pretty brutal yeah i
just wish i had enough time to like go
to the beach or you know even go to the
pool or anything but like i didn't even
have enough time to do that we were just
tired as well because we've been in la
for like a month we were in the uk
before so i think you're just dead
you're just so dead yeah yeah i was
[ __ ]
well we did get the taste of la life
guys
how did you feel because we actually i
think
this so what we did was you were
currently in the la arc on trash taste
um and we what we did was we rented out
an airbnb and we used it as a studio but
also it was kind of like our first
experience living with each other as
well
in terms of living with each other sorry
it's like a disney show
just a couple of friends
just filming some videos
what will they get up to yeah we
basically just made a trash taste house
you know because everyone in l.a thought
we already lived next to each other or
by each other
and that wasn't the case in japan
[ __ ] we live actually pretty far away
from each other like
close enough that we can get to the
office but
not close enough where we could easily
make content with each other like
everyone else does in l.a games yeah we
just don't live together so yeah yeah
exactly exactly uh yeah and i i thought
it was a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] blast
honestly living with the boys it was
really really fun but i feel it was fun
because of the time limit that we had
right like if you told me you know no
offense to you boys but like this
applies i feel with anybody yeah right
that's not like your significant other
or whatever if you lived for long enough
with each other i feel like you're going
to be [ __ ] sick of each other and i
feel that's why a lot of content houses
just don't work out in the long run
right because it's like it's it's a
honeymoon period to begin with but then
the longer you're with together you're
like
yeah i kind of value my privacy as well
yeah
i might have my own room but it's not
quite the same
another thing i noticed as well is that
if we did have a trash taste house like
a trash taste content house i don't
think i'd get anything done no because
these boys are distractions like
normally normally i want to hang out
with you
normally i go i i wake up go to my
office i'm like great work starting you
know catch up to emails or something
this time i go up go to the living room
see mailing or jerry up and i'm like oh
what are you what are you up to what are
you up to what do you just like have
breakfast and chat for about three hours
yeah just things just go slower because
you're talking to other people yeah so
like whereas maybe i get lunch and i eat
in 10 minutes so i go right back to work
at my house yeah lunch becomes like an
hour and a half yeah exactly exactly
it's good though i think is this the
first time i've gone to la where
i
went with the like express purpose of
trying to make like as much content as
possible
so it was really fun because i there was
like no days where i wasn't
uh doing hanging out with someone or
making something and so it was really
satisfying because i
but for me it's like
i i feel like i get my battery recharged
through making content um yeah i'm
[ __ ] addicted to making like youtube
videos
right here yeah so like for me it's like
if i'm not doing that it's like oh i get
like i'm like oh i want to make
something yeah i want to film something
so it was like a whole month of just
being creative and getting to perform
and getting to go on stuff it was just
great you are you are truly a shining
beacon for content creators
like i i think people are like oh dude
i'm like no dude i [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] like this is what i'm addicted to
like i don't know why like i love being
on i love being on [ __ ] shows i love
doing events like yeah yeah it did
constantly like la did constantly feel
like you were filling up a progress bar
or like something in terms like content
or connections or projects or something
even if even if we weren't like actively
filming something every day but even so
i still felt like i was way more
distracted in la than
i would normally be at home yeah i feel
there were just like too many nights
especially when like most or all of us
were just like hanging out for the night
where i was just like i could be in my
room streaming or making content but i'd
rather just go out onto the balcony and
just chill with everyone yeah
there'd be so many times where i'm like
i could just set up a like we had like a
bare bones basic stream set up in one of
the rooms and i was like i got time to
stream but joey's out there chilling
maybe maybe i'll go chill with joey for
a bit and then i'll just have like a
quick five minute chat and then we'll go
stream and then seven hours later
and then the five minute chat turns into
like half an hour then we've got to get
lunch and then you know we're meeting
someone in like an hour so i'm like okay
i guess i can't stream you know yeah i
would i might my main channel would be
non-existent yeah if we had a trash
taste house i feel yeah i can see why
there are so many streamer houses now
because you know living your life is
just [ __ ] content at that point
pretty much uh and if you if i had to
like actively go out and make the kind
of content i do my main channel that
just wouldn't [ __ ] happen if we had a
trash taste house no i'm not yeah these
boys are too much fun yeah exactly it
was just very motivating though yeah
yeah i got very motivated oh yeah
definitely to make more stuff and push
push it i'll shout out to ludwig always
uh the inspiration yeah he was so nice
yeah i can love that guy yeah
i feel like he's my long-lost american
brother
disconnected from that i honestly feel
most if not all the like new and old
faces we met up in l.a were just like
really really nice people
yeah you know and yeah no it is true
like i always get a massive kick of
inspiration out of like hanging out with
someone who perhaps i've never met
before but i know their content or like
you know some other content creator i
don't get to see or talk too often and
you know like conventions for me are the
same thing as well just like you know
being in a convention setting which we
were a lot this past couple of months
just like it's like oh yeah this this is
why i do this like this is this is this
is just motivating me to like do better
for these people you know yeah um yeah
no so it's good i i mean you know i may
not have been
necessarily motivated while we were in
la or while we were traveling but after
i came back to japan i had like a
[ __ ] list of ideas so you know that's
that's always good
i feel like it's important for every
content creator to get their content
battery recharged and i feel like the
best way to do that is just to hang out
with other people
hanging out with other like creative
people because so many ideas get thrown
around and you're like damn all right i
could actually do this all right i've
got so many ideas now whereas if you're
just sitting in a room just constantly
pumping out content it kind of like you
just get into a grind and you get into
like it's monotonous yeah it does get
monotonous a lot of times and you forget
why you started doing this in the first
place and one thing i will say about
hanging out with so many people in la so
many other content creators is that it
definitely gets those
creative juices flowing again yeah
absolutely yeah especially seeing some
of the like seeing the what motivates me
the most is seeing other people do
something exciting yeah because then i'm
like damn i want to do something yeah
this looks [ __ ] incredible exactly
exactly
and la is just like the central hub of
that
um but yeah aside from that there were
it was i mean did you guys enjoy your
experience in la overall oh yeah i
[ __ ] loved it yeah me personally yeah
yeah i i enjoyed la i think because of
the people i got to see yeah if i if i
didn't get to see anyone and i was just
living in l.a you know without ever
interacting with other content creators
personally
no
yeah just because like i don't think the
la lifestyle necessarily meshes with me
yeah i i i [ __ ] hate the lifestyle
but when i was there i had like an
amazing time oh yeah yeah definitely um
and also i mean i i hate to admit it
there's some amazing food there oh no
the food's great oh that's food that was
some amazing amazing god i must have
ordered the porto's cubano sandwich like
a million [ __ ] times that that [ __ ]
went hard
in california nutty yeah yeah also joe
and the juice yeah yeah no so we have
during the juice in the uk right do we
we do okay and there's one in australia
as well so it's this coffee [ __ ]
chain and like i don't really care for
their coffee but in the in the one in
america
they sold like this sandwich it's like a
spicy tuna sandwich and it was so
goddamn good me and joey must have eaten
it like five times i i think i ate it
like ten times i was so goddamn good i
froth of the mouth every time i think
about that my comments go back i know i
just i want to go back just for that me
and joey we had one in la yeah i was
like you have to try this tuna sandwich
i know i know you're going to love it so
he tries it like this is insane yeah we
pull up to our hotel in miami
at the bottom of the hotel is a joe in
the video literally like the next thing
over from the hotel wasn't john there's
just like it's fade we're like fish
bomber like nice
so every morning we would just wake up
and be like coffee and tuna spicy
sandwich i got you
i think i only had one bad meal in l.a
um what was it was it the attack shame
them yeah yeah yeah okay oh my god yeah
dude you remember this do you remember
this
i think i think on like the third day or
something that we all arrived together
we wanted to go to one italian but it
was like uh it was like a saturday was
uh look at the bapo we were originally
going to go to boca de beauvo because i
[ __ ] love it but yeah yeah as god was
saying it was a weekend so we were like
a book of the pepper is probably going
to be really [ __ ] crowded so let's
find one on the way and then we found
this uh one italian place i don't even
remember that it was like family earned
we thought oh that'd be that'd be good
to support a local business yeah exactly
exactly
and maybe we shouldn't have
how do i regret it yeah i forgot like
the one golden rule of like like how to
judge a restaurant which is if it's peak
time on saturday and you go in and it's
almost empty that's that's a bit that's
a big red flag
also to do with this restaurant i had
been told this and i come from japan
right if a restaurant has four stars in
google
it must be good yeah exactly good
exactly apparently in america if it's
not higher than 4.5 it's dog [ __ ] is
what i've been told really that's what i
was told is it the 4.5 4.5 is apparently
the like if it's higher than that it's
you can you know it's good right right
don't maybe americans are just nicer do
people just rate in america four stars
if the food is edible i i don't know so
remember when we got there like yeah
we got absolutely scammed right away oh
yeah right so
it's all coming so we pull up into this
restaurant right and
there's clear parking spots right yeah
so and there's valet though there's
valet parking right no one is here no
one is in this restaurant this may be
like
we should have turned back at this point
honestly yeah so we go in the we gotta
start parking our car and this guy comes
over and he knocks on the window he's
like oh uh valet service eight dollars
and we we i think we misunderstood that
he we thought that he was like oh you
have to pay it right right but i think
it was you offering it yeah
so we were like oh okay so then we get
out the car hand him the eight dollars
and he literally just continues backing
it up into the spock and gets out and is
like all right there you go he was he
was probably in the car for about eight
ten seconds ten seconds like ten seconds
tops that man got the biggest conversion
of time to to payment uh and known in
history it's like those memes of like
bill gates when he drops a hundred
dollars on the floor it's like
it was literally the car was basically
parked and then he just went
that's it
and i couldn't believe this man took our
money i couldn't believe he was still
willing to take dollars for that i'm
like only and only in the us
am i if this happened in the uk fist
would be thrown if you try to get the
eight dollars off of me it just wouldn't
work that's why we don't have valet
parking but that wasn't that wasn't the
only thing yeah yeah yeah so that set
the tone yeah that definitely said
that's wrong
that was the red flag i think all of us
were just like we we all stood there and
we were just like we just got robbed
yeah yeah we we this is like
i can't believe you've done this yeah so
yeah we uh immediately go into this
restaurant after losing eight dollars
um and then afterwards we go in it looks
pretty it looks like a pretty decent
restaurant um and so
sorry no
say something yeah
yeah
i don't like it when restaurants do this
and this is just for me preference i
understand that people don't care if i'm
in an italian restaurant and you're
trying to like set an ambiance don't
[ __ ] play an mlb game in the corner
on a giant monitor like i'm sorry to me
it's like that's not the italian vibes
are ruined but there was just like two
giant sports games and they were just
playing the audio and i'm like
also there was a very american looking
bar in the middle yeah yeah yeah well
that's fine i don't care about the bar
being in the middle right i just it's
like
i think it's got a mood i think it's i
think it's the bar in combination with
dmob on the screen that just made a very
non-attack yeah it was like two giant
like 50 inches on the wall blasting this
audio and you're just like eating your
thing and you're saying and that's a
strike and that's a
thank you
and it's just like ah this is just like
what am i am i crazy like is this weird
this is weird right
yeah so i i get you i get you because i
like i don't like that in restaurants
either where they play a game or
something like that okay yeah at a bar
okay i get it i get it it's a bar yeah
yeah it's the time in a place it's a bar
it's a bar this is this is a restaurant
you know i i would prefer to you know
just have some music and uh just have
that set this thing up if you went on a
date there you would look bad that's
what i'm saying yeah ambiance would
already make it look you're in a rough
spot
better make up for it yeah i mean like
everyone ordered their food and of
course of course i was like
i gotta try the lasagna all right all
right because i i think that's my
default thing i order every italian
restaurant that's like that's how i
gauge how good the rest of the italian
food is right because you'd have to like
try an italian would have to try really
hard to [ __ ] up a lasagna sure because
there are way more like complicated
dishes in the italian cuisine so i
always rewarded lasagna um
and then
i will say the guy did look a bit
panicked when you ordered the lasagna he
was like
okay
he's like oh that one yeah he was like
oh you're ordering that one i was like
it's been a while since i've had lasagna
and of course it it comes out and it's
probably been an order it's probably
been a while since they ordered this
yeah it comes out and i'm just like oh
that looks it looks a little soggy
that looks like a little bit of a soggy
lasagna it was it was something like
what 20 something dollars yes like 20.
like this but it wasn't like a giant
piece either no no no no normal size
it's like a 28 like but like all the
dishes in that restaurant were about
like yeah they're all at least 20
dollars eight dollars quite a lot of
money it's a lot of money um and i like
i put my fork into it and it just
[ __ ] this this pasta just
disintegrates right
this thing wasn't made out of pasta it
was made out of air and
i'm like i've never seen pasta so soft
in my life yeah and i take it i
i take like my first bite and you know
when you can immediately immediately
tell that you're just going to have the
worst meal of your life yeah so god
looks so disappointed
everyone everyone was like staring at me
because i because they were so excited
because like oh go and order lasagna
let's see let's see what he thinks about
it i take one spoonful i think my face
conveyed everything that needed to be i
wish i had taken a photo of the face
that you had made because it was like if
you looked up disappointment in the
dictionary that was the face
because the first bite first of all the
pasta was soggy all of it was soggy yeah
it somehow even though the pasta even
the lasagna was like full of tomato
sauce somehow they've made tomato taste
nothing taste of nothing like i don't
know how you make tomato taste of
nothing because it just it was cold on
the inside right as well and and it was
called it was so obviously microwaved
yeah as well because the hot the outside
was super super hot but then the inside
was lukewarm and i was just like this is
this is yeah to the restaurant's credit
my dish was actually pretty decent i
think i would have like a uh a lamb
pasta it was pretty good actually yeah i
like uh i like a gnocchi i think which
was like it wasn't the best gnocchi i've
had but it was it was decent i know you
should you get lasagna to see if the
restaurant's good yeah i feel in my mind
if i get the calamari that's how i can
normally tell because the calamari is
one of those dishes where it's it's
really easy to buy it frozen yeah and
just deep like chuck it in the [ __ ]
deep fryer yeah just call it a day but
like if they actually care you can tell
that it's it's fresh and it's not
[ __ ] rubbery and then you know it's
everything else could be good because
that's a very specific thing that you'd
have to go out of your way to make sure
it's fresh that's true that's true that
was bad i mean like it wasn't worth the
money it was just too expensive it was
so expensive it was yeah it was
definitely i mean the gnocchi was like
decent but i would not pay the amount i
paid for it yeah yeah i mean like one
one of my biggest pet peeves when i go
to a restaurant is that
i like as someone who grew up in like
the whole restaurant kind of like area
you do you sh if you can't make a good
dish don't put it on the menu like you
know what i mean like there are some
restaurants i go to where they give you
the menu and it's just the entire
history of your country's cuisine i'm
like there is there is no [ __ ] way
you can cook all of these dishes
and like a good kind of
there's like 200 items on the menu it's
like
are you sure
yeah like i get it if there's that one
guy comes to your [ __ ] restaurant
he's just like oh why don't you have
this dish that everyone else has you
know i'm just like you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you know just serve good just
serve the dishes that you know you can
cook really really well five to ten
items i feel is like i feel a good
middle ground because it's like you know
maine's yeah okay like five to ten mains
i think is like the good middle ground
because it's like you know those five to
ten mains are gonna slap we went to
another italian place that was really
good around the same price and it was
amazing oh yeah so good oh yeah the one
we went with uh yeah yeah amazing and it
was i think it was around the same
prices for like everything yeah yeah and
i thought wow okay well so it isn't just
like i'm i'm being cheap it's like no
these are the same prices we just got
ripped off in this one yeah yeah but
that's how it is and that made me
understand more like when i went to more
independent uh restaurants and more uh
coffee places a lot of the time i kind
of understand why a lot of people just
want that familiarity of a chain well
you know what you get because it's such
a gamble in the u.s oh like oh it's a
gamble everywhere yeah but like in japan
you like
you you gotta be pretty unlucky
like you talk about the us being a
gamble let's talk about the [ __ ] uk
the uk's are sad this is the same though
this is why like restaurants in the uk
like and cafes like a lot of the
independent ones struggle because a lot
of people don't like they want that
familiarity yeah and they want like you
know when you go to a [ __ ] wendy's
you know exactly what you're getting
sure yeah whereas if i go out of my way
i i take a date i pay a [ __ ] ton of
money and i get half-assed meal pasta
i'm like [ __ ] i should have just gone
olive god like i know what i would have
got yeah yeah cause we we talked about
the us having like the 4.5 google
reviews kind of meta the uk just doesn't
have a meta when it comes to google
reviews you just like people in the uk
don't know how to review food that's
that's just the end or be all the water
was not spicy five stars
because i've been to restaurants in the
uk that's like
seven four point eight i'm like okay
this place must absolutely slap
it's awful
like really there are some places that
are out there like the ratatouille
critic
i'm about to end this restaurant's
career
hold my pen
to be fair to be fair i've like see in
recent years especially this trip i have
discovered way more decent restaurants
in the uk that i that i had that i did
than before i moved out of the uk i
think that i think the uk have just
definitely upped their restaurant game
um yeah because i don't know what you
experienced beforehand but this was the
first time for me that i probably
explore explored london and like the
food culture surrounding and i'm like
why is what are people complaining about
this is actually pretty decent maybe i
just got lucky i don't know but yeah we
just have it we just steal other
people's food and uh you know that's
good
i mean australia kind of does the same
thing yeah we don't have like a cuisine
it's like what do you want like there's
probably someone here who makes it like
church do you want like new zealand rat
[Laughter]
because i remember when we went to the
uk i think maylin landed and i think two
days after she landed she'd had like
four meals and she'd message me being
like in all caps do reviews not mean
anything here
how do you know who to trust how do you
know which google review to trust and i
was like do you review things i don't
remember i review things really oh i
never i never even looked at google
reviews before i moved to japan oh okay
yeah right now
because i just looked at something and
i'm just like oh that looks like a
couple of photos i'm like yeah that was
good i review things i feel like
people like me are keeping society
together without me there won't be
there's so much chaos how will everyone
know what did you always review though
oh yeah i've been doing it for a long
time okay so before you move to japan
yeah before i move to japan because like
i understand the culture here because
you review something it means something
here yeah you throw you throw a review
in the in the uk google reviews it's
just like a message and you throw a
[ __ ] message in the bottle into the
sea like it's not gonna reach anyone man
it's like a message in dark souls
i am guilty though of the whole
five-star one-stop meta i am guilty of
that what do you mean i'm either a
five-star guy or a one-star guy you've
never rated anything three stars no i
have i just like in my head
if something's three a lot of the time i
want to go back and confirm it's a three
yeah but also why would i want to go
back to the three because you're kind of
indifferent to it right yes i'm like
yeah whatever yeah yeah and like some
places i
like a lot of the times i've gone to
restaurants i've ordered one thing and
i'm like and then for some reason i've
gone back and i've got a different dish
and i'm like oh oh this is just this is
so much better this dish like i just
happen to get the dish that they do
poorly right you could argue that that's
like reflective on them and they that
they shouldn't put it on the menu it's
better whatever but i feel like it can
vary so much whereas like if you have a
five-star time you're like everything
was perfect it was amazing staff were
amazing ambiance oh everything was
amazing right all right well five stars
where on the on the inverse side where
it's like if it was all [ __ ] i i knew it
was all [ __ ] right she's terrible so you
just nip it back yeah so i never go back
and give it one starts right right but a
lot of the times i
the places i go to in japan are just
purely off recommendations yeah so
i kind of normally go to places that
i've always really liked i've not gone
to many places that i haven't enjoyed in
japan yeah because everyone is always
like this is my favorite restaurant so i
go tricks i'm like oh it must be pretty
good i mean yeah at the end of the day
word of mouth i think is the most
effective way of finding oh dude yeah
honestly some play some places in japan
aren't even on google reviews or they're
not they're not on it if you just search
restaurants near me or something like
that yeah next kind of restaurant i'm
looking for sometimes you have to like
really really look uh and that's why
word of mouth means so much here in
japanese food culture because people
follow what other people say and if you
see a huge line at a japanese restaurant
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] slaps even
though i never think it's worth waiting
an hour for any meal in my life sure
sure [ __ ] that yeah i'll go to
mcdonald's
i'm not waiting
of waiting well outside of a restaurant
yeah 20 minutes tops i'm not doing more
yeah for me it's like no more than 30.
yeah i think 30 minute is the absolute
limit it really depends like okay if we
have like 20 people and they say 30
minutes i'm like we're waiting 30
minutes we're not gonna find somewhere
else so it's like but if it's just me
and someone else 20 minutes tops yeah
and it's going to be a restaurant i know
it's true otherwise i'm like 10 minutes
yeah because it could just be a huge
waste of time and the food is kind of
mediocre yeah i'd rather just go
somewhere if like if you're in an area
where there's a bunch of restaurants
nearby i'd rather just go somewhere else
just the name yeah yeah
that's true yeah one one one small thing
that annoyed me in some of the
restaurants we found in l.a was that you
know sometimes we were in a group we
wanted to go out have a nice meal
together all right let's phone up the
restaurant and book a table you find out
the restaurant they're like we don't do
bookings yeah it's like a thing in l.a
right turn up in the door and i'm just
like why why
yeah a lot of the restaurants we went to
wouldn't accept i never understood why
that's the case is it so to avoid people
flaking out i think
i there must be some math behind it
where someone has worked out that you
can make more money and get more
customers in the door by doing it just
turn up right because if they're full
and you can't reserve then you're not
going to show up but maybe you want to
go maybe they can squeeze you in if
there's two of you right i feel like if
for the restaurants that are in really
high demand it must make more money yeah
because you can get more customers in
yeah yeah people are willing to wait 20
15 minutes at the door right right so i
i feel for like yeah like what was it
like sugar fish whatever
sugar fish was one of them there was i
mean
we went to the first italian restaurant
we went to before we found the other
italian restaurant yeah yeah yeah that
was that was the biggest thing because
also when you when you go one day and
you can't get in you're like i should
come back again because clearly it's
good everyone's waiting and and to be
fair the restaurants where i did have to
wait we're pretty damn good
i i feel like yeah it's a strategy to
just make more money
and also you don't have to deal with
reservations not showing up yeah i think
i think that makes more sense to me than
because you you lose money right if you
serve a table and they don't show up or
they show up 20 minutes late or 15
minutes late or they show up 20 minutes
early and you're like
it's not ready basically they've just
min maxed restaurants right
but but you know when there's a group of
like four or more preserving is like
amazing because it's like we know that
we can turn up at this time and we'll be
good and japan's great for that that's
why i love japan yeah because you can
reserve any or most places except except
for a danny's it's not it's not even
japan in most places in the world i've
been to there's
most restaurants do reservations and
three two to like i've okay let me let
me rephrase that i've never seen this
system ever anywhere outside of l.a i've
never have you ever seen it anywhere
outside of valley i'm sure it's in like
new york a place like that you call them
up and they they say no reservation yeah
there's places that just don't take
responsibility well other than like
other than like [ __ ] mcdonald's
the restaurant meter mcdonald's every
other restaurant
la restaurant donald's is a restaurant
all right the restaurant
the family
for families i guess so yeah because you
know because you know throwing it back
to the time we tried to reserve for
seven people
and they were like we don't take
reservations just show up please i'm
like oh yeah we'll pay
we really want that denny's though
yeah
this episode is sponsored by high dive
guys have you ever heard of the anime
i'm quitting heroin yeah it's pretty
interesting i already watch anime well i
actually met with the author a while ago
for a panel discussion and the plot is
really interesting it's a fantasy show
where the hero wants to be basically on
the evil side for once
why would he do that well god i would
tell you but you'll need to watch the
show to find out which leads us to
today's sponsor high dive because did
you know that i'm quitting heroin is
exclusive to high dive huh i didn't know
that and what is high dive town question
connor i'll tell you and the audience as
well high dive is an anime streaming
platform that has tons of anime titles
like arkham mega kill food wars no game
no life to the newest series like i'm
quinny hero no game no life the anime
i'm still waiting for season two for of
course the anime is gonna be subs right
heck yes it is
dubbed and sub content for all anime
but isn't that going to be pricey do not
worry because it isn't at all high dive
is much more affordable compared to
other streaming services so sign up now
and you can even start your seven days
free trial oh my god i just did some
math if you watch two anime a day that's
14 titles in the for this free trial
period what god connor you are so good
at maths so go to highdive.com to start
your free trial now and thank you to
heidi for sponsoring this video back to
the show but um how did you guys find uh
australia
that's that's what i want to know i
absolutely [ __ ] loved australia yeah
i found like my long-lost second home in
australia man so it's like i've said
this so many times before but i
australia to me was like the uk except
everyone there was just way happier
that's because the weather's better i
guess i don't know the wildlife is
cooler the weather is better um you know
things a lot more things to kill you
if you built the uk from like like a new
fresh account yeah in in a good climate
right
it's like if you build the uk from a new
fresh account but you've played the game
before yeah yeah yeah right so you know
yeah
no because like i've never you know
truth be told i've never felt like super
patriotic about australia like you know
i love australia don't get me wrong it's
my home but it's like i've never been
like yeah aussie aussie aussie until
the boys came to australia and i was
like
do you like it
please please
would you please say you like
yeah thank god we did it we did it
australia we did it yeah it was honestly
i don't really have any complaints about
australia wow i'm i'm like i'm like
trying i'm like trying to rack my brain
over something i can complain about
because we're [ __ ] british and we
need to complain about everything and i
guess the only thing i complain and i
can complain about is the lack of
anything to complain about basically
like every every australian was like oh
so sorry for the weather so sorry for
the weather i was like what what why are
you apologizing for the weather this is
[ __ ] amazing weather
it was a bit [ __ ] what are you talking
about it was a bit it was a bit cloudy
yeah i think it was just a shame because
we were really tired so we couldn't
really like have a hundred percent i i
want to have a vacation there for sure
yeah oh yeah yeah i feel
especially when it comes to sydney
because you know we were there mostly
for you know the convention yeah yeah
twitch stuff and stuff like that yeah i
feel you guys didn't really get to have
like a proper view of
sydney i guess to a reptile park oh yeah
i guess yeah you went around like alex
took you around yeah but like i feel
like you and sydney didn't really get to
see like actual sydney sydney yeah yeah
like but i mean you at least you got to
experience melbourne yeah yeah because i
after the uh after smash tour and i
traveled to melbourne because we had
some uh i have some family there who
i've never visited in australia
um
and it was [ __ ] fantastic because
they live right like they live more on
the outskirts of melbourne they live
near yarra valley which is basically
just a bunch of [ __ ] wineries so i
was me and sydney just had a whole
[ __ ] field day just going around
wineries one day they took us around
you're engaging in an australian
activity yeah yeah that is yeah wineries
is an australian activity
exactly how could i complain when we
just like what we did to to be showing
around was being shown around a bunch of
wineries and just trying a bunch of
[ __ ] wines beaches wineries and
breweries that's just australia saw some
uh saw some kangaroos on a golf course
that was that was weird oh yeah yeah i
got to i went up to like little baby
kangaroos you can like pet them and
stuff yeah it was fun yeah yeah joey's
yeah little girl yeah
seeing kangaroo i've never heard that
one before
seeing kangaroos like up close in real
life for the first time um
just made me like just confirmed with me
how [ __ ] batshit natural selection
was in australia like i just what
[ __ ] happened to natural selection
australia i don't get it that's what
happens when you have a server
completely isolated from any other
server sure like even just looking at
kangaroos right i'm like how the [ __ ]
did
what what what happened in the history
of kangaroos to lead your evolution
because you know basically everywhere
else in the world because what i've
realized is that kangaroos are basically
just australian deers right
they're basically just australian deers
but like in every other in in every
other side of the world
animals just decided okay four legs
walking on four legs that's the meta
that's the most effective meta and then
all the way in [ __ ] australia
kangaroos are like that's just [ __ ]
bounce everywhere right
does not even [ __ ] walk let's bounce
everywhere like what the [ __ ] happened i
mean if you're talking about dumb
[ __ ] evolution the koala is like the
king of like [ __ ] stupidity
like
when you hear like when i did the irl
stream we got to hear about the koalas
and literally every single koala
attribute had like 20 caveats right they
were like so goddamn dumb they all they
could only eat one [ __ ] plant yeah
eucalyptus tree and the best part is is
that if you take the eucalyptus leaf off
the tree they don't know what it is yeah
they're like i can't eat this yeah what
is this what's this leaf what is it what
i don't know what this is they don't eat
it how how and also the reason why they
sleep for 16 hours a day is because the
toxins and the eucalyptus leaf basically
act the same way that marijuana does to
humans so they're just stoned
that's what i realized koalas just are
just the [ __ ] stoners of the world
yeah they're just stoner bits yeah
that's all they are and the babies have
to eat the mom's poop right yeah yeah
like i found this out at the smash con
panel where koalas have to like when
koalas are born the mum needs to eat the
eucalyptus leaves and [ __ ] it out yeah
right because the because the baby's
stomach isn't strong enough to break
down the toxins of the eucalyptus tree
because it's technically toxic yeah how
the [ __ ] did this animal survive in
australia one of the most dangerous
places in the world in terms of wildlife
how how the [ __ ] does that happen you
know like they literally lucked out by
putting all their points into cuteness
if humans didn't exist they'd be [ __ ]
man oh yeah absolutely cuteness only
from a distance though because like i
don't know if you ever got like did you
ever get to get like really close to a
quality yeah i got to touch it does it
not smell like [ __ ] oh yeah they all
smelled really good they smell [ __ ]
horrible actually yeah yeah well yeah
they they're literally born eating [ __ ]
so of course they're gonna smell like
[ __ ] as well like there are a lot of
maintenance to keep them happy i think
as well yeah otherwise they just die
they're just like ah [ __ ] it i'll die
yeah guess i'll die
literally they will they're too stoned
to care man
[Applause]
i feel like you guys didn't even get to
see like the truly weird animals that we
have no we didn't even
we only saw your base level animals and
those were [ __ ] weird enough yeah
because i remember you were freaking out
about like all the wild cockatoos right
oh yeah yeah the birds are crazy yeah
yeah but it's absolutely insane also
birds [ __ ] they're cute as [ __ ] yeah
they're awesome yeah we need more
exciting wildlife you guys are you guys
freaking out about the iverses was my
funniest thing ever because we're on the
pigeon matter in the uk you've been on
the pidgeot matter for that like
like hundreds of years the pigeon and
seagull mata yeah true true i mean we
have seagulls as well
even your seagulls look way more
aesthetic than rc goals really yeah yeah
they do they do what do your seagulls
look like hideous
i don't look at a seagull and go like
damn that's a good looking bird though i
didn't do that until i went to australia
and saw your seagulls they're so like
slim their beaks are nice and polished
they're actually clean and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] are the seagulls in
england be eating you know these eagles
been growing up from the [ __ ] streets
well they fight each other yeah they
fight each other every day in the uk
yeah but gone telling me about uh the
ibises was so funny yeah those are weird
i never thought about how weird that
must be to someone outside of australia
because i'm just so used to it what are
the ibis again the bean chicken or the
bin chickens yeah yeah yeah i just like
it's this by the way for those of you
who've never been weird
it's just like why like i'm surprised
that like
australia like allowed them to exist
yeah
because they feel like i feel like when
an animal gets too big
it just gets like destroyed yeah because
it gets destroyed yeah because i said
the reason why we can't [ __ ] keep
tigers alive because they're too big and
easy to [ __ ] capture sure yeah
because i feel like it's too big of a
bird it's not nimble enough it looks so
weird as well yeah yeah literally like i
remember i remember like the first time
i saw it was actually walking right in
the center of the streets of sydney oh
so many of them yeah there's so many
because normally i'm used to just seeing
pigeons and seagulls in a city i'm not
and then i suddenly turn the corner and
this massive [ __ ] bird with a really
long thick like no a really long slender
narrow beak and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that yeah yeah yeah can they fly yo
is that a pokemon oh yeah
uh nothing
honestly is there any like do they do
they have some ecological uh service
that they do for the
what are they they they they eat the
trash i guess oh that's why they're
called bin chickens because they're
always rummaging around because they're
like they're basically the rats of
sydney do you like spiders get rid of
flies and stuff yeah yeah yeah you know
what would have been chickens yeah i
don't know what
what have been look look up the purpose
of an ibis
like what ecological roles do they serve
in the hierarchy i don't know like to
entertain us yeah yeah funny chickens
entertainment to entertain foreigners
what the hell is that
yeah no like every time i don't know
because i think i'm just so used to it
that like every time if i'm like eating
outside or something and there's just a
bunch of ibises like
walking around i'll just be like
[ __ ] off yeah yeah you know because like
i don't i haven't really ever seen or
heard of an ibis like attacking someone
or like someone getting hurt
oh they got a long beast they just
[ __ ] stopped speak out the way it's
like you're gonna do it
just grab it by the beach
[Laughter]
i don't know do you know what it is
i figured that out okay okay tell me
what it is
everything we hate gets rid of another
insect i don't think i've ever seen an
ibis on a farm though they're always
like near the coast aren't they because
they're like just like
me i just discovered these things were a
month ago i don't know like they're in
this they're in the middle of the
[ __ ] city i don't see a farm in the
middle of the city i think speaking of
bin chickens and terrible meals in l.a
reminding me of this i went to medieval
times
you know oh okay no you haven't seen
medieval times do you ever watch cable
guy no the movie jim carrey where he's
not where he's the cable guy no it's a
really good one explain yeah right so
medieval times is this kind of um is it
like a renaissance fair or uh it's like
a pantomime performance where there's
like an arena and there's like knights
of different colors and the
the seating areas like a stadium mini
stadium oh cool they're ranging to
colors and everything everyone gets a
house color right right and you sit and
you watch the performance and you get a
meal your drinks as well
and um yeah so then these dudes come out
and like white red or whatever and they
all do like games to see who's the the
best knight and then they have a fight
at the end to decide it's all
choreographed
and they all talk with british accents
and some some of the actors nail it and
some of them oh god there's this one
actor who like it sounded like sylvester
stallone tried to do a british accent it
was so bad
every time he spoke i just couldn't like
because i was with emily and died i just
couldn't stop laughing and then they
would start laughing so like connor he's
trying his best
it's just so bad he's so bad
um but it was really fun it was
interesting they're really [ __ ] good
at their job yeah i mean
yeah it was a fun performance i thought
i was going to hate it because i was
like ah it seemed really true is the
meal any good or oh god knows
so i what did you get
i i i mean to their credit it was
accurate to the 1200s
like you don't get a knife and fork
which i'm fine with i'm fine with i just
i didn't know that so when i got a whole
chicken and a garlic bread and a soup i
i was like oh oh i just i just like grab
it
did i get no i don't think i got a knife
how the [ __ ] are you supposed to eat the
soup you just grab the plate just like
that or yeah i think so just use your
just cup with your hand
yeah yeah you do
yeah
you're starving
yeah literally it was all with your
hands because like i remember they gave
us like two moist towelettes and i was
like rationing them while trying to eat
this full like quarter chicken right and
and there was no seasoning on this
chicken and this thing was bone dry
right bone with a capital b dry
right no no no no because the soup was
just tomato soup and it was like the
exact kind of like you know that if you
had to mass manufacture tomato soup
that's the exact taste it was
okay
can i get this straight i'm not
complaining about the food because i i
expected it to be good i know that when
you go to a pentaminos thing you're not
going for the food yeah of course but if
i could have like had my an option but
he didn't expect to eat like a peasant
if i could an actual peasant if i could
have had an option to not eat the food
and eat somewhere else i would have done
that
oh it wasn't even an option to not have
the food no no you you get the food oh
and they gave us garlic bread bro and i
tap this on my glass and don't don't
don't
again again i don't care i literally
don't care i just thought it was funny
at least the show was good right now the
show was great
dude they were really whacking each
other with these metal swords because
there was like sparks flying out oh [ __ ]
it was hype as [ __ ] i got really into it
i was
screaming anyway this chicken chicken i
was like nearly i was in like the sahara
desert by the end of it i was drinking
i had like a four liter beer as well
guess how much it cost me
four four liters it was like three liter
beer i'm exaggerating
guess how much it cost me it's uh 20 30
bucks maybe how much do you think it was
i think about 30 bucks yeah it was 35
yeah this beer and i didn't know this
because it wasn't well explained to me
or maybe i'm just dumb i didn't listen
so you paid 35 american goddamn dollars
for unincluded tip um i i don't know if
i had a tip it was i was just at a bar
something like a service charge or
something i think so yeah yeah okay so
apparently you get to then refill that
i think you get to keep it i did i
didn't keep it because i didn't know
that but apparently refill the glass
with beer yeah yeah yeah right well then
that's [ __ ] that's worth it yeah no
no no that's all you can drink for 35.
for the refill how much
eight or nine bucks oh that's not too
bad right but i mean getting through
three liters of beer in like an hour and
a half show how many beers can i chug
bro like that's that wasn't even the
worst though remember the [ __ ] beer
that i bought for everyone at the
[ __ ] mogul money
oh remember how expensive that would be
like a can of corona it's like a can of
corona for like 18 and i'm just like i i
bought four so we were all in mogul
yeah let's let's go to the bar and you
know buy a can of beer because it's a
show
yeah and i was just like guys don't
worry i got this one you know i was
feeling good that day i got full like
you know tall boys of beer it was like
96 dollars i'm like all right okay
that's fabulous that's the stadium
i actually tried to okay i didn't i had
to ration this [ __ ] out i didn't tell
you boys this about what happened before
you bought the beer yeah because the
reason joey bought all the beers was
because
uh to get into this venue you had to you
either had to have like a
a clear bag uh or you had to like put
your bag into storage or or it was a
small bag or it has to be like a really
really small bag like a bomb yeah so my
bag was too big to go into the security
and this bag is tiny yeah yeah it was a
really really tiny bag um and so i was
like great i'll just put my bag into
storage that's no problem i'll bring out
my credit card just in case need to buy
something i put it in and then only
after i go into security
do i remember
oh yeah my id was in that bag and i
completely forgot to bring my id
and so
and so
we go up we go up and it's it's like
it's actually pretty chill right it's
not like we got grilled or anything like
that they just you know they just ask
for id
and so i tried to explain that you know
i didn't have my id but i'm [ __ ] 32
okay i'm i'm i'm 32. i forgot my bag uh
i forgot my id in my bag that's in a
storage case ten minutes down away uh i
i asked me where i was at 911
and so and so they were like do you have
any kind of form of id on you that we
can take at all
and like i look at him then i was just
like
do you uh so this is going to sound
weird
but i have a wikipedia article
and i have a favorite should we do that
and they were like oh are you serious
can i see it and so i i load up my
wikipedia article and i can see this guy
just he he he looked at it and he was
just like [ __ ] is this a form of id i
can actually accept and he actually
considers it for about like a minute or
two and i'm like please guy my guy come
on look i i am actually 32 and he's just
like
oh sorry i don't think i can accept that
but if but if you get someone else to
buy it on your behalf aka joey then
that'll be fine so that's that's why
they allowed joey to buy it for me
you literally pulled the
i'm kind of famous
like this is the first time i've ever
tried to flex the fact that yeah okay
okay
yeah
there's some mileage out of it you know
that i i hope they [ __ ] normalize
that from now on though
like that's photo id yeah
famousbirthday.com yeah come on my
photo's there my birthday's there
i can't believe that's something i would
do
that's a me thing that's not easy
i was desperate for a [ __ ] beer okay
because i because the reason is we once
we went in we couldn't go back out so
there was no way i would i thought there
was no way i could get a beer for this
show and i was like i can't sit through
a [ __ ] three-hour show so why are you
kidding me
that's how i'm british of me you know
um yeah the beer was stupidly expensive
i paid like 90 bucks for four beers and
i'm just like what the actual [ __ ]
that's where they're making all their
money not these [ __ ] tickets of
course of course yeah i guess i guess
the medieval times one was good in
comparison oh yeah i don't think what
time is good though it's a good show you
should go sometime it's fine oh i loved
it that sounds really really fun yeah
yeah it was surprisingly good they did
the whole thing at the start of the show
where they read out everyone's birthday
and it was like timothy uh 11 years old
congratulations oh yeah i'm on a kids
thing technically that's good fun though
oh yeah get a good piss up with the boys
yeah hell yeah that sounds fun yeah we
should definitely go next time yeah
going back to australia though one thing
i did notice uh hanging out with
australians is that
australian sarcasm is just on a level
that i've never seen before okay
because how sir because here's the thing
it's like you guys are constantly
looking for the next target to prank and
you never talk about this verbally but
as soon as you say as soon as someone
makes up a lie or jokes about someone or
about something to a foreigner or
something everyone just univer everyone
in australia universally agrees to get
in on this joke oh yeah yeah right and
that's why like one thing i didn't
understand before going to australia is
like why every australian just agreed to
try to trick the world about drop bears
yeah which uh what what is like the drop
bear law what do you mean trick they're
real
this guy this guy
like they pretend like people live in
australia
yeah right you all would live in a
[ __ ] house no one lives there it's a
simulation so when i saw this happening
first hand yeah it was uh we did a
stream in australia where like we found
out what tim tam slams were
yeah that was my favorite thing we found
out what happened uh we found out what
team time slams were so tim tam slams uh
so tim tams are kind of biscuits in
australia like a chocolate biscuit yeah
it's like two uh two biscuits with like
a chocolate filling and what happens is
you bite you bite off two corners and
you put it in tea or coffee or whatever
whatever and then you suck out the uh
liquids literally no point in doing this
yeah absolutely no there's no benefit to
either the drink i think i think you
have to know how to do it in order to
get a visa yeah australia but um yeah
it's definitely on the citizenship test
that's for sure but we did it because
they're you know because we're on the
australia set and the the live stream we
did was australia theme so they were
like oh let's just get the boys to do a
team team slam exactly completely failed
at it yeah um but one person who wasn't
there was sydney
and
we were we had a panel together
where
someone asked us on stage if we'd done a
tim tam slam and obviously me and me and
connor had just done one so we said yes
and sydney's like what's a tim tam slam
and for some reason as soon as she said
that everyone every australian perks up
and i was just like this is this is
content right here this is content right
here and then so joey jokingly says okay
so what happens in australia when you
get a pack of tim tams is you just slam
it on the floor and you just [ __ ]
slam it uh until it's [ __ ] until it's
crumbs and you eat the crumbs and that's
the tim tam slam yeah right and then you
know and and you know uh the crowd and
the the emcee were all just like yeah
yeah that's he's right and the thing is
i
me being british i was like they said
that so sarcastically yeah of course
sydney's never going to fall for that so
in my mind i was like i thought sydney
got the joke yeah i thought sydney had
gotten the joke
so
she didn't really question it she was
just kind of like oh okay yeah okay
and so
after this the next day we all had a
signing together
and someone in sydney signings
brings her a pack of tim tams
and then
and then she go and then he goes oh do
you mind doing a tim tam slam for me
and sydney goes yeah of course of course
i'll do it
i know what that is so i'm sitting
necessarily just signing away and all i
hear next to me is just
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] cindy
what are you doing what are you doing
sydney she's just like i'm doing my
tim's up slime why are you stopping me
why are you stopping me i'm like sitting
there sort of
they've tricked you
as soon as i said that everyone every i
swear every [ __ ] australian everyone
in the queue looked at me and i was like
god what are you doing what are you
doing why would you say that and i was
just like how how have you all just
agreed to just like try to trick
everyone that you've everyone that
you've met were they just was everyone's
gonna watch her batter these biscuits
absolutely i was going to she was
battering it for like a good few seconds
and nobody said [ __ ]
everyone was everyone was just like yep
you got it you gotta just keep doing a
couple times
being like you got this queen all right
next step you just gotta pick the crumbs
up and eat it and i'll just like
it was so funny i was impressed
oh my god that the australia chose one
of the most boring [ __ ] food items to
be like their mascot like it's literally
just a chocolate biscuit and it's a very
very ordinary chocolate tasting biscuit
like you guys can't talk you you guys
are like yes
chips and a fried fish listen the uk is
not any better right but i expected
better from australia because you had a
do-over you got to do it right and you
were like oh let's just get the generic
ash chocolate biscuit which we have we
have tin times in the uk they're just
called [ __ ] normal chocolate biscuits
like we have the exact same type of
biscuits we just don't care because
they're nothing special but yeah but
australia decided oh this is gonna be
our thing and you go to the airport and
everything's tim tam themed in the gift
section like this is [ __ ] yeah no it's
just no it's because it's it's because
it's the most uh non-challenging food
item that any foreigner from any country
can be like yes that's good that's
acceptable i like chocolate i like
biscuits right like it's kind of
difficult to be like you know oh so
australia we have this thing called
vegemite and we have this part
it's good and we have this party food
called fairy bread uh favorite [ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly right it's good
two opposites right here but i think
anyone of any palette can agree that
like yeah [ __ ] who doesn't like
chocolate biscuits
i don't like drinking biscuits well
that's a you problem everyone else
everyone else likes chocolate biscuits
so that's why we used it as like a
marketing method as a kid i like
chocolate tasting stuff and then you
know what happened as i got older i just
felt that chocolate tasting things just
taste bad and like really artificial
almost i don't know why
even though it's not because a lot of
times you melt chocolate in it or just
put chocolate i don't know why i mean
like i i'll i'll admit that i don't eat
as much chocolate as i used to
definitely i can't eat as much chocolate
just like physically because i start to
get sick but like i'm not i'm too sickly
i want to go as far as to say that i
will just pass up chocolate at any
chance i can get like normal chocolate
like chocolate bars i'm there but like
chocolate flavored things it'll be
really sickly am i i don't know
personally i don't know if given the
chance i can i can slam a packet
he said that i'm just like okay go ahead
have your opinion what do you why
chocolate flavored things whoa something
about chocolate flavored like chocolate
ice cream chocolate biscuits just makes
me feel kind of sick
is this is this is crazy i can do this
again are you playing devil's advocate
or is this your favorite
this is genuinely how i feel that's
there's no way you actually believe that
i believe that it's a [ __ ] copious
that's how it is when i taste chocolate
flavored things i'm like literally any
other flavor would be better than this
bro you you advocate for vanilla i love
vanilla you advocate for vanilla
chocolate i'm sorry vanilla is an
amazing taste
i have a feeling you've said an opinion
about chocolate where you were praising
like chocolate flavored things in a part
maybe i'm just tripping maybe our
audience will remember chocolate bars
like milk chocolate dark chocolate bars
i [ __ ] love i think that they're
amazing but that's like the that's like
just the chocolate in its purest form
give me the [ __ ] cocoa bean bag and
to [ __ ] shove it in my mouth yeah but
that's like chocolate cookies i don't
really like chocolate cookies fudge uh
fudge is okay chocolate cake chocolate
cake is too much oh my god
[Laughter]
i am trying to process i can i can hear
the blood boiling in here i just think
there's too much chocolate like shoved
into like per bite but like you fudge is
like even more intense than chocolate
cake is and you're saying chocolate cake
some fudges are okay but
it's some
brownies brownies okay brownies are good
but brownies isn't like more heavy they
say but they [ __ ] up that's like
concentrated chocolate yeah brownies are
like got to be warm brownies as well i
don't like cold brownies well nobody
likes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay
there we go there we go i don't know
just i don't know brownies uh again like
and i can't i i'm sure you're the same i
i don't know anyone anyone who could eat
like a [ __ ] ton of brownies like i could
wash it
that's the stone when you talk yeah okay
like stoners be like oh just watch me
i'll bet
plain fresh cookies chocolate chip
perfect like that's that's perfection in
the cookie to me
right a chocolate cookie is too much
too much chocolate flavor
i'm not trying to say this i'm trying to
comprehend this is not one of my
opinions where i'm like i believe that
you both are wrong and you should
definitely 100 understand my like i get
it that oh don't worry we're not this
could definitely be
the weird opinion why is so much dust in
front of me what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened just like sneeze getting that
old
dust particles in my face yeah so i
think here there's dust in my face
[Music]
my oxygen has been compromised but it's
[ __ ] dust
um
yeah no i i i just think vanilla is an
amazing flavor um of course you do
um
yeah it's just too sickly for me i i
know that that's not normal though i
know that's me yeah okay look don't give
her like i understand the point of too
much chocolate it gets me sick right
because we think but that's a lot of
sweet things like too much vanilla will
make me sick as well i will say one of
my favorite desserts is uh sticky toffee
pudding that's good though that's like
more i like it when you have the
chocolate stuff with like a big like a
sauce or something to help with the
flavor like a chocolate sauce for
instance no no chocolate sauce on
chocolate is [ __ ] disgusting that's
way too much well that's that wouldn't
that be like a chocolate lava cake like
you don't like those no no actually
they're okay it depends
it's like a few bites like one or two
again it's a sickly thing it's not it's
not a taste thing it's a sickly thing so
are you like this with any other sweet
things or is it just specifically
chocolate sticky toffee pudding is like
way more sickly than anything chocolate
yeah that's why you have the vanilla ice
cream to neutralize it you know what i
mean yeah okay so are you the same with
vanilla ice cream for instance like if
you eat enough vanilla ice cream will
you get some no i can i can go to town
on vanilla ice cream
that was our same brain cells just
firing off being like yes
oh connor has an opinion again yeah it
is it is it's the slow head zone of like
excuse me i i i'm sure there are some
other people out there who think that
chocolate is too sickly
no i agree with you on chocolate beans
that's actually like
that's actually that's actually a common
opinion
a lot of chocolate is very very heavy
this is the problem tastes right is that
i don't know if my opinion is a general
shed opinion and you two are just clowns
it's a bit of both i think we're all
clowns here that's a bit of a point
that's the point of it you can't just
dismiss every chocolate item aside from
chocolate bars
i know
uh what was the [ __ ] fountain what
are you talking about
the lava cake whatever yeah lava
chocolate cake right great example one
bite god tier i love that [ __ ] it tastes
great mm-hmm two bites i'm like oh my
god i feel like i'm about to [ __ ] do
that's why literally you use the same
strat as you do with the sticky toffee
pudding you never have a chocolate lava
cake by itself
or ice cream or a whipped cream
toffee sauce is a game changer yes i
just love toffee toffee's great
i like i i hate toffee for the same
reason you hate chocolate stuff because
exactly yes way too sickly i like i i
don't like caramel stuff it's a weird
one because i know i i especially on
this chocolate thing i contradict myself
a lot yeah so it's very much dish
dependent i i get you on the fact that
like too much chocolate is sickly but
i'm like that with all sweet things not
just chocolate like if i eat enough
[ __ ] strawberry flavored ice cream or
like vanilla rice like for me i think
i'll get sick i think chocolate ice
cream has got to be like bottom tier
like [ __ ] f tier it's like one of the
ones no strawberries bought them too
strong okay okay strawberry
do we agree boys
strawberries strawberry ice cream unless
they they use like god tier fresh
strawberries and it's made up yeah but
it's never i know it's never done no no
nevertheless you could say that's the
same thing about any kind of like
dessert right you use the fresh
ingredients yeah it's gonna be better no
well then that's like okay every every
like ice cream or dish or milkshake or
whatever has that it has that the
distinct like
uh cheap flavor that every like flavor
alternative has like banana has that
cheap flavor yeah yeah chocolate has
that cheap flavor go-to right strawberry
has that but so does vanilla uh yeah
yeah vanilla but i think out of all of
them like the cheap flavor like
strawberry is probably the worst one oh
yeah and then chocolate because i i
realized like two of my favorite fruits
are strawberry and banana right i
[ __ ] love eating those fruits
yeah absolutely
gods here but i hate anything that's
flavored like them you know i like
flavored things do you like banana ice
cream uh yeah yeah yeah i like banana
flavor but it's not my go-to it's it's
it's like my fourth choice listen if i'm
getting the banana i'm getting three
scoops someone is one of them like i
need something else to ride right right
because yeah dude i mean there's this
one there's an ice cream place in
hokkaido and so got it's like a chain
that you want to get in hokkaido dude
they do like the most insane flavors of
ice cream and it just makes ice cream
like another level it's like you just
can't go back to here but that's just
hokkaido just being but like it was like
it was like you'd get ice cream and it's
like tiramisu ice cream and i'm like i'm
just i'm just there for that like that's
i am there okay that is a game changer
and there was caramel macchiato ice
cream i what oh my god that's
if that's what it means to eat ice cream
like that i'm i'm on board then would
you ever order a sorbet for dessert oh
[ __ ] no sorbet is sorbet is dog [ __ ]
here of like i think the problem with
sorbet is that you can have really good
sorbets but at the same time you can
have some real dogs
sometimes it's so bad
what are you doing you must have had
some really [ __ ]
when they tell me
i'm like come here just tell me you
couldn't afford gelato or ice cream just
just say it okay because like you've
literally complained about chocolate ice
cream being too heavy sometimes you have
a heavy meal you're like they bring out
the dessert
just come in just give me a just [ __ ]
come out with a tune teaspoon and just
pour the flavoring directly in my mouth
don't give it to me through this icicle
[ __ ] i don't want a [ __ ] ice cone
right it's not even an ice hole it's
like an ice cream that you literally
just caught sorbet it's like a hard ice
cone bro it tastes like [ __ ]
if you need a light dessert if something
creamy like ice cream cone sometimes i
have a meal so
i don't want a knife it's not creamy
enough it's just that's the whole point
of it cream's heavy it's not meant to be
a heavy dessert it's like it's like
just admit it you're you're you're a
snow cone with like a droplet of cream
just get it out of the way some
sometimes you need a dessert that's a
different kind of heaviness to ice cream
sometimes i don't want ice cream to
finish yeah sometimes i don't want ice
cream and sometimes i don't want fruit
as a dessert sometimes i want it's like
it's like the sorbet the probably
strawberry mainly is okay one the
texture's awful i just don't like it
because i'm also i'm a i'm a snow cone
hater uh and and it's it leans too
closely to that kind of okay you know
like you don't like cocky guardian
snowflakes
it's awful oh my god um and
also my other problem with it is that
every sorbet flavor just seems to be
awful like they just they they can never
make it it's literally like fruit
flavored a lot of times you know like
do you know like orange orange orange is
the worst flavoring known to man i think
orange is like orange
orange has to be like
okay i said strawberry from australian
sarcasm or are you like actually serious
like i i know we said that strawberry
was down there and now that i would
remind me because i must have blocked it
out because i don't want to exist
strawberry is by far by far i think the
worst flavor of any fruit it's so bad
strawberry oh sorry uh orange sorry
orange is such a chocolate oh
right but the moment you get just orange
on its own i don't like too much
chocolate orange flavor sucks but orange
chocolate though orange chocolate damn
it's the rare combination where two
flavors if they you know they they drop
their differences they can come together
make something decent but
i hate chocolate i hate orange orange
chocolate two negatives three negatives
make a plus it's where you should never
rule out possibilities right i just
think that orange sorbet awful like
orange flavored drinks orange flavored
ice cream oh it's just so bad it's just
so bad i think i think i think i figured
it out connor just has some of the most
skewed taste
like
food that i've ever seen where it's like
you you really like what you really like
but you really don't like what you
really do i just think that like and you
are so [ __ ] particular about [ __ ] if
i went to a restaurant and it's all
i had for dessert no i'm not i just i
was
someone who won't eat it like if you
give me an orange sorbet i'm going to
eat it but i'm going to be begrudgingly
annoyed the whole time that you gave me
an orange so you're just a stubborn
picky eater no no no no i i will eat
anything i got a real can you give me
this [ __ ] slimy thing i'll stomach it
and i'll be like fine i'll [ __ ] eat
this slimy thing i don't want to eat but
i'll eat it like i really because every
yokan we've been to together you've
passed me the slimy [ __ ] immediately if
you're gonna eat it let's
let's let's move back for a second my
point being is a picky eater somebody
doesn't eat it i will always eat it
right yeah let's move back for a second
what is this tirade against oranges what
it's literally the vanilla of the fruit
world how'd you hate how do you hate
oranges
it is such it's not gonna because
vanilla is quite mild in flavor right
it's a very like light flavor it's not
intense orange it's a very intense
flavor you just hate it it's so acidic
okay let me guess do you like orange
juice no i hate orange we've said this
before i hate orange juice do you just
like because the thing is oranges are so
[ __ ] refreshing do you know
refreshing stuff it's like acid
[ __ ] ass how weak
it is it is absolutely because there was
a lot of fruit juice you know i feel
literally most fruit juices
of the citrus family lemon and lime
absolute god tier they figured it out
how to make it refreshing you literally
want to have a raw lemon versus having a
raw orange
yeah definitely
are you serious like i know lemon is
like more acidic but like the flavors
that you get in like lemonade are less
acidic than you get in say orange juice
like orange juice is always way more
acidity yeah that's because lemonade is
very different to lemon juice i know the
lemon flavored things are also nicer i
find
hold on
there's so much [ __ ] that's being
spewed right now that like i'm having a
trouble processing like
orange juice
is is awful like it's just a it's just a
bad drink like it just doesn't taste
good you're so you are so wrong you're
so wrong i mean you're
just there's there's not enough well
there's not enough hats in the world to
indicate how much cap that is man that's
like i'm just trying no there's viewers
out there who are watching this who know
that orange is [ __ ] who knows that
sorbet is bad who knows that chocolate
is too much yeah
orange is like oranges yeah your altar
count
your 10
orange is like by like it's probably
like one of the worst fruits no no
like aren't people what's truly the
worst so also orange is just a miserable
eating experience it's just terrible how
are you eating about are you eating the
rind like it's just like a banana
[ __ ] easy as [ __ ] you should get it
what do you want do you know a thing
there is a thing called a knife
but no knife needed i love that
i wanna [ __ ] have to peel this open
like a caveman banana easy bro you lit
you just [ __ ] cut it into quarters
the banana has an elegancy to it the the
the orange you gotta [ __ ] pry it open
like a caveman scrambling for his meal
you literally have to do that with a
lemon and a lime as well though i don't
eat [ __ ] lemon and limes on their own
you literally just said you would rather
eat a raw lemon than an orange i would
never do it there's an elegance he says
the banana you could it's oh yes oh yes
oh yes
don't mind if i do there's an elegance
he says talking about the fruit literal
apes eat you know there's a reason why
they
they don't want to fumble around with an
orange it just makes more sense it
literally has two iq like
he's just like too many steps
also i just think the texture of like a
i just think everything about the orange
i just dislike like with the texture of
eating an orange i feel like the texture
oh no like the texture of bananas are
like not good it's waste waste it gets
way too much it gets weighted it gets
way too mushy
okay okay look it's it's a gamble with a
banana sometimes you gotta have the
perfect texture for it to be like yeah
that was a [ __ ] amazing look
sometimes the banana can be too hard
sometimes it's just a [ __ ]
here thinking that banana has the best
texture of any fruit no it does when
it's when it's the optimal texture to
a perfectly ripe banana is the best
vegetable strawberry strawberry
watermelon watermelon watermelon's good
that's no not enough taste not enough
taste
strawberries like the pop rocks of fruit
excuse me it's okay
what did you say huh there's not enough
taste in watermelon
it's a very light flavor it's a very
very light flavor it's diluted it's
mostly it's literally mostly water yeah
that's why i like it yeah i will say
out of all the names like our orange is
pretty good i mean it's i assume the
color was named after the fruit yeah
yeah but watermelon yeah they were
pretty ripe by calling your watermelon
yeah
i'm not getting clickbaited yeah yeah
yeah i know exactly what i'm going in
for with the watermelon and you you have
a better time
melon is better than watermelon just
because there's too much water in the
watermelon
no there is just far too much water like
i am getting way too hydrated eating a
watermelon how can you say that apple
juice is the worst juice no so how can
you say that orange juice is the worst
juice when apple juice exists yeah that
is i think i think juice is literally
that is water that that is like that is
like
toddler they are like they are like they
are like neck and neck to me like apple
juice just
apple juice just wins in my mind because
it's not orange but it is just as bad
what are you what is this orange slander
orange what is this orange racism the
worst fruit i think it's by far what did
oranges ever do to you i don't know just
completely my entire life every time
i've tried it i just think this tastes
like [ __ ] like did you get beaten up at
school like you're wearing an orange
shirt or something like why do you hate
art i don't know if it's like the
british ancestry of scurvy and [ __ ] like
i would rather get scurvy than even
orange
bet
i rather would i would scurvy challenge
incoming let's go
i just don't want to i just don't want i
just don't know what about what about
orange zest when when there's a dessert
or something we fancy dessert
are you curious about orange liqueur i'd
rather not if i don't like i again i'd
rather any other i'd like any other uh
citrus liqueur if possible i like
literally i'm trying to like process
what where this hatred comes on comes
from because i'm like
maybe it's like the acidity i don't know
and then you you go you come here and
say you'd rather eat a raw lemon than
[ __ ] did your father throw oranges at
you when you like misbehaved
like not the
oranges on an orange one
oh those oranges just taste bad
i don't that's what i just think it's
the like you have there has to be a
worse fruit in your mind right what was
from an orange in your mind what's the
worst fruit the worst fruit dragon fruit
oh it's such a cop out
what do you mean it's a cop people don't
[ __ ] eat that at any time like it's
just
talking about niche fruit are you
talking about fruit that we can buy from
fruit that you can get anywhere in like
a daily life yeah you can get dragon
fruit
japan where you can buy dragon fruit
that's near you right now uh literally
the supermarket in my house sells drying
fruit bro what was your supermarket some
got like [ __ ] whole foods uh erin
like that's privilege right there
that's actually privilege that is a
privilege indicating yeah except it's
like a tiny [ __ ] corner there's like
two dragon fruits at most you know i'm
still there i've never even seen dragon
fruit in the store
you're probably not working okay so that
doesn't count because that's [ __ ]
fruit it doesn't exist okay so like a
common fruit right common fruit
what's the worst fruit the fruit that
you you when you thought about anything
like no no i'd rather not you know i'm
trying to think and i know you're trying
to pull something out of us i literally
can't think of a fruit i just don't like
what a cop out i i just
i'm sorry i just like fruits okay
if i had to like pick something okay
no i figured it out this is this is just
me personally but for me it's grapes
what yeah i'm not a massive fan grape's
a god to you what are you talking about
joey i know you like wine how could you
hate grapes how could you hate grapes
the reason why grapes is that's like
saying how could you hate bread you like
beer it's like there's nothing alike i
have to say grapes are the like and this
is this puts it in s here for me grapes
yeah it's the only fruit where you can
always get the perfect amount of the
fruit that you want like you can have as
many grapes as that suits you always if
you want a [ __ ] ton of grapes go down go
to town and it's also such a satisfying
eating experience
i don't know i'm just not a massive fan
of grapes i'll eat grapes but like i
would rather ha i would rather cut an
orange open than eat some grapes i'm
gonna say this that's just me personally
though i'm just gonna say it i'm i'm a
vegetable guy all the way i think
vegetables are so goddamn superior to
fruit in every single way you just hate
desserts you just you just say sweet i
just like sweet stuff like vegetables
are just so much better i hate sweet
stuff if it's not vanilla like if if i
had to pick guns in my head worse fruit
even though i don't really hate it
probably apple
like there's there is no category some
experience eating in the airport it's
like there is no category that apple
goes in that is that can't be beaten by
another fruit i think i i think it's one
of those i like i like i like green
apples i'm not huge into red apples i
don't like red granny
smith so yeah green ones granny smith
green apples banger i i it's i know i
really like eating apples actually but
it's just a lot like there's always a
lot of apples yeah it's one of them it's
actually i think it's the most filling
uh fruit oh absolutely yeah absolutely
and it feels like you eat like ate a
[ __ ] a380 it's like it's a whole meal
so much food like if the apples
especially in japan where the apples are
like [ __ ] this big like that's a meal
um so yeah that's kind of where i stand
on it i just think vegetables are the
superior ones they're more look don't
give me something so
also vegetables are better for you just
saying is is that the reason why you
hate sorbets just because you hate
[ __ ] fruit i hate fruit flavored
things so
i figured it out you just hate [ __ ]
so if there was a vegetable flavored
sorbet would you oh [ __ ] no that sounds
awful why would you want that just just
a hypothetical no no no no no i i would
want i i just want okay first of all
don't want a sorbet i feel like the
texture of it is just the worst i could
like i think a vegetable sorbet could
work i just gelato like a like a gelato
and soft serve and normal ice cream all
the way
but like sometimes sometimes
there are sometimes never an occasion
where i will say no there are
there are some times where you've had
such a [ __ ] filling heavy
main course but you still want something
just to like take the edge off because
let's be real that's so bad
let's be real that whole saying of like
oh dessert is another stomach it's
[ __ ] no no no no it's not it's
actually not it's proved that you're
stuck you can actually make more room
for dessert because the way i can't the
way that it works with sweet and salty
is that you can trick your brain into
thinking that there's there's more room
than there is i'm sure that's why you
over eat i'm sure at the time yeah but i
know for a fact i stopped myself from
doing it because i know i'm going to be
sick afterwards there's been a lot of
studies on this you you can actually
make way more room when you're when you
have something sweet right
i do notice well that's just variety of
meals
if you have one of like the same thing
over and over you can eat you can you'll
you're gonna eat less of it but it's
emphasized when you go for something
savory it's something really sweet uh
just because of how i don't know how
much stupid brains work yeah
um so but yeah but the great thing about
ice cream is the moment you eat it it
becomes a liquid so it it'll definitely
fit in there so does sorbet it'll make
room
in fact
in fact
is more liquidy wait no no you're
putting your argument on me i never said
that it's too heavy you're you're you
just put your [ __ ] argument on to my
ice cream love i never said ice cream
was too heavy i never said sorbet was
too heavy
sometimes ice cream is too heavy
it's not it can't be too heavy because
it'll always fit in your [ __ ] stomach
that's not the point the point is the
feeling of it right and cream is way
heavier way heavier fruit juice it is if
i if i use the same amount of ice cream
versus the same amount of sorbet i would
feel more sick with the ice cream than
the sorbet like like the exact the exact
same for the exact same reason why you
can't eat too much chocolate ice cream
versus too much vanilla ice cream it's
because vanilla ice cream feels lighter
than the chocolate right i mean it's
just it's not so much there it's more
just feels more i don't know why it
makes me feel sick immediately i don't
even know what we're arguing about
anymore
i'm trying to argue understand too many
arguments happening at the same time
this is this is just there's so many
[ __ ] taking husbands just been said in
like uh 10 minutes
we just turned preferences into like
solid set and stone takes that must be
followed yeah because you're making it
that way i'm just saying my opinion and
then you guys are like connor has an
opinion what
that's
it i just said i think orange is a dog
[ __ ] which they are
chocolate as a flavor kind of sucks
everyone knows that vanilla is the best
uh well we can we have the right to uh
[ __ ] argue your shitty opinion you
know
well i'm not saying that this is like
you know 100 that's what it has to be
all i am is calling you a clown and i i
think i think that's fair
you're entitled to your opinion but you
definitely said the most unpopular
opinion well we don't know because we've
had takes before where i've said it and
you guys are like no you're dumb as [ __ ]
and then all the comments are like nah i
can't as well come on this is the trash
day saudis
well the whole is the whole keyboard
thing all over again i was completely in
the right there and i was i was un
unjustified and i was i was uh
reprimanded for no reason and i was
completely in the right with the
keyboard argument god forbid you're
correct sometimes
i've got this is gaslight central i'm
always getting gaslight here on trash
taste it's very fun i just can't believe
you hate oranges i've never met a person
hate orange no i mean he's driving
the the only person you're assuming
but the only person i know who doesn't
like oranges is someone who's like
allergic to oranges what no no no no
there's a lot of people out there don't
like orange it tastes bad
i guess you i'm sure in the comment
section we'll meet a lot of people why
don't you follow like-minded oranges not
someone i want to be friends with that's
for sure
what if someone in your family doesn't
like orange what if you don't know i'll
[ __ ] clown on them for the rest of my
life
what if aki just turns around she's like
i just can't i'll absolutely clown her i
just can't imagine a world where you
just i can't imagine what we don't eat
your [ __ ] crusts
plenty of people don't need that crust
actually plenty of people don't need
that
we're gonna bring blood
don't pretend like this is where you
draw the line this is oh no everything
else goes out of the window because
orange is now that's where i'm like that
i'm not i'm not i'm not saying that i'm
not i think we can all agree that we are
all clowns but today we get to clown on
this [ __ ] clown we've all we're all
guilty of having a couple of opinions
added to the [ __ ] list but you just
added another entry onto yours we'll see
we'll see we'll see we'll see all the
view i'm pretty cocky there'll be a lot
of fellow orange haters out there
i guess let us know in the comments if
you're an orange hater or an orange
lover
it sucks fantastic it's the worst fans
of socks don't get me just taste like
[ __ ] orange fancy socks like what world
would you pick fanta over like yeah but
orange fanta doesn't taste anything like
orange no
orange orange soda doesn't taste like a
little too much like orange for my taste
no it's got it's like like orange fanta
sucks because it's artificial orange
taste if something actually tastes it's
the same reason why i hate every art is
the same reason why i hate strawberry
ice cream yeah and other artificial
tasting fruits uh it's fruit flavors
it's because it doesn't actually taste
like the [ __ ] fruit we'll see what
the comments say we'll see
he's like running to the comments like
guys help me yeah
you guys
i just can't believe i just like i'm
yeah it's like i'm just more shocked
that you have such a strong opinion
towards [ __ ] oranges they just suck
i just i
can't you'll catch me first okay
i can understand i can understand if
your opinion was you know i'm not really
like a fan of oranges um but like i know
i've never seen someone so
spies and orange yeah spite oranges they
just suck they just [ __ ] suck
oh my god this is enough fruit slander
before i
have an aneurysm yeah yeah i'm gonna
have a nice orange flavored dessert you
know what i love you know i'm gonna go
home
you know what i actually love orange i'm
gonna go to my local supermarket
i'm gonna buy a couple of oranges i'm
gonna buy dragon for it and i'm gonna
have a good time actually you know i
[ __ ] like now it's just to do it but
you know actually slaps orange jelly
have you ever had orange jelly yes oh my
god that's like one of the most
refreshing desserts oh that is like
double nightmare for connor he doesn't
like jelly or oranges
hey look at all these patrons though
check them out i wonder how many of them
are orange lovers how many of them are
orange haters
i [ __ ] love is like one of the best
feelings in the morning is coming like
coming downstairs i'm just coming all
right of course it's just coming
coming up coming downstairs and having
like a nice refreshing orange juice to
go with your breakfast
oranges i know they're great they're
really good for yourself i love oranges
i've never met a man hate oranges before
today
but uh thank you very much to your to
the patrons hey if you'd like to join on
patreon then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.comtaste also follow us
on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit if you hate our facebook and
sales on spotify we're gonna see a lot
of orange memes so uh redditers enjoy
those uh but yeah i guess connor's
[ __ ] off now uh i'm gonna go eat some
oranges with my boy right here all right
we'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you